Okay,
so the last time we were here we got
about maybe a third of the way through
his story,
his story of no kill and the
transformation of a marionette into
something hypothetically real.
And I'm gonna backtrack a few slides and
it'll get us into it again.
So you remember that.
Um,
the blue fairy.
So I would say the benevolent element of
Mother Nature in the ski matter that
we're going to use to investigate
mythology had more or less been allowed
her entrance because Japan was a good
guy and because he wished for the right
thing.
And so in some sense here,
here's a way of thinking about that,
you know,
genetic studies,
genetic slash environmental studies of
children's temperament have revealed
something quite interesting,
which is that the shared environment
that children have within a family.
So that would be what's the same about
your environment and your brother's
environment.
The Se doesn't have that much effect on
your temperament or his temperament
because the presumption always was that
within a family there was a shared
environment,
right?
That something was common about the
environment to every child within that
environment.
But,
but there isn't much of a shared
environmental effect on temperament and
so then you could say,
well,
that makes it appear as though parenting
isn't that relevant in relationship to
the development of temperament,
but you could also suggest something
else.
You could suggest that if parenting is
occurring properly,
the effect of the shared environments
should be very close to zero and the
reason for that is that you establish an
identity on an individual relationship
with each child and the environment is
actually a microenvironment that's
composed of your observations of your
child and that specific child's
interaction with you and to some degree,
if there is a shared environment that
means that you're enforcing the same
principles on every child.
And so my suspicions are,
although I don't know this because the
research hasn't been done that in bad
families there is a shared environmental
effect,
but in good families there are there
that minimize it.
And so that lets the child's biological
predisposition roughly manifest itself
with support and in some positive
manner.
Well,
I don't want to extend the analogy too
far,
but you could imagine that if,
and this is what this film proposes,
is that if you aim properly in
relationship to your child,
what you're trying to do is to establish
an individual relationship and to allow
them to move towards whatever their
particular expression of individuality
happens to be and that's while that
would be the same as allowing nature to
take its course in some sense at nature
and it's positive guys,
and that's exactly what happens here.
Now the other thing that happens of
course,
is that the cricket for reasons that
aren't clear precisely is knighted by
the Blue Fairy and serves as Pinocchio's
conscience.
Although he isn't very good at it,
which is a very peculiar thing and quite
a market,
a point that the film is making that
that conscience actually has something
to learn too and there's actually a
Friday and element to that.
You know,
because Freud thought of the Super Ego
as the internalization roughly speaking
of the father,
and it could be very severe,
the superego.
So it'd be like a really strict father,
really tyrannical father.
Inside your head,
although I think it's better to think
about the Super Ego as the internalized
representation of society at large
mediated to some degree through your
parents because it's not as if your
father even assuming he's too radical,
is the inventor of all those tyrannical
rules.
He's the propagator of them,
but he's actually a proxy voice if he
even if it's just for the harsh side of
society.
He's proxy voice for society and because
we are social creatures,
the the utility of having an internal
social voice to guide you.
Although again,
you seem to be able to follow it or not
follow it,
which I also find spectacularly
interesting because obviously if it was
an unerring guide,
you could just follow it and if it was
well you wouldn't need freewill either
because you could just act out the
dictates of this internal representation
and that isn't what you do.
So anyways,
the proposition here is that the
conscience exists but it's a relatively
flawed entity and it needs to be
modified as well by nature.
Which is quite interesting because the
blue fairy night,
Sam,
because you also might think of the
conscience as only something that's
socially constructed,
right?
Which is the more typical viewpoint.
But I don't buy that for a second
because I believe firmly and I think,
I think the pig jetty and interpretation
of child development more or less bears
this out,
is that there are parameters within
which conscience has to operate and that
it's sort of like this.
It's like the same parameters that
govern fairplay will say that.
And so you can say there's fairplay
within a game and there's fairplay
across sets of games and the set of
games is pretty much indistinguishable
from the actual environment,
right.
If you think about all the things you do
is nested games at,
at some point,
the spread of that is large enough so it
encompasses everything you do,
which includes the environment.
And so,
uh,
I believe that you're adapted to the set
of all possible games,
roughly speaking all possible playable
games,
something like that.
And that,
you know,
the rules for that,
which is why we talked about this a
little bit.
Why you're so good at identifying
cheaters,
you have a module for that.
According to the evolutionary
psychologists send you,
not only do identify the but really
remember them.
It really sticks in your mind and
there's other evidence to so one piece
of evidence that I love.
I think it's so well there's a couple.
One I would derive from friends to wall
who's a famous primatologist and he
studied.
He studied the prototype morality that
emerges in chimpanzees and it's very
much rest nested in their dominant
structures,
you know,
because you could think of morality in
some sense as the understanding of the
rules by which the dominance hierarchy
operates.
Right?
And so you could say,
well,
the biggest,
ugliest,
meanest chimp and the male dominance
hierarchies in chimps seemed to be the
predominant ones.
Although the females also have a
dominance hierarchy in it.
It's not quite so clear in Bonobos,
which seemed to be more female
dominated.
But in any case,
I'm the champ.
Primary chimp dominant structure is male
and you could think,
well,
it's like the cave man champion whose
biggest and toughest to necessarily
rules and who rules longest,
but that isn't what the wall filed.
See,
the problem with being mean,
let's say,
and not not negotiating your social
landscape and not trading reciprocal
favors,
is that no matter how powerful you are
as an individual to pete,
to individuals,
three quarters of your power can do you
in,
and that happens with the chimps fairly
regularly.
If the guy on top is to tyrannical and
doesn't make social connections than
weaker chimps,
males make good social connections and
when he's not in such good shape,
they take them down and viciously to,
to wall has,
has documented some unbelievably
horrendous acts of,
let's call it regicide in among the
chimpanzee troops that he studied mostly
in the Arnhem Zoo.
They have a big troop there that's been
there a long time,
but he's very interested in prototypical
morality.
And here's some other examples of
prototypical morality emerging among
animals.
There's many of them,
but one is um,
you know,
have two wolves have a dominance dispute
that again,
that would be more likely among the male
wolves,
but it doesn't really matter.
They basically display their size and
they grow for all shipley and puff up
their hair so they look bigger and you
know,
you can see cats do that when they're,
they go into fight or flight,
right?
Not only do they puff up including their
tail,
but they stand sideways and the reason
they do that is because they look
bigger,
right?
Because they're trying to put out the
most intimidating possible front.
So anyways,
if two wolves are going at it,
they're.
What they're really trying to do is to
size each other up and they're trying to
scare each other into backing off
fundamentally because see,
the worst case scenario is like your
world for number one and number two.
And we tear each other to shreds,
but I win,
but I'm so damaged after that,
that wolf number three comes in and
takes me out.
So like there's a big cost to be paid
even for victory in a dominance dispute.
If a degenerates into violence and
animals and human beings,
but animals in particular have evolved
very,
very specific mechanisms to escalate
dominance disputes towards violet by
step so that they don't so that the
victor doesn't risk incapacitating
himself by winning.
So what happens with the wolves is that,
you know,
they growl at each other and posture and
display and maybe they even snap at each
other,
but the probability that they're going
to get into a full fledged fight is
pretty low.
And what happens is one of the wolves
backs off and flips over and shows his
neck.
And that basically means all right,
tear it out.
You know.
And the other wolf says,
of course he doesn't,
while you're kind of an idiot and you're
not that strong,
but we might need you to take down a
moose in the future.
And so,
you know,
despite your patheticness I won't tear
out your throat.
And then they've established their
dominant position.
And then from then on,
at least for some substantial period of
time,
this subordinate wolf gives way to the
dominant wolf.
But at least the subordinate wolf is
alive.
And you know,
he might be dominant over other wolves
and so everyone in the whole hierarchy
is sorted that out through either
through mark combat or through combat
itself and you know,
the low ranking members aren't in the
best possible position,
but at least they're not getting their
heads turn off every second of their
existence.
And so there's even some utility in this
stability of the dominance hierarchy for
the low ranking members because at least
they're not getting pounded.
They're getting threatened,
which is way better.
I mean it's not good,
but it's way better than actual combat.
And then there's the example of rats,
which I love.
This is Jaak Panksepp work and he wrote
a book called affective neuroscience,
would I,
which I would highly,
highly recommend.
I have a list of readings,
recommended readings on my website.
It's a brilliant book and he's a
brilliant psychologist.
Really one of the top top psychologist
as far as I'm concerned,
both theoretically and experimentally.
A real genius,
Huh?
He's the guy who discovered that rats
laugh when you tickle them.
They laugh ultrasonically.
So you can't actually hear them,
but if you record it and slow it down,
then you can hear them giggling away
when you take a look with an eraser,
which is sort of like their mother's
tongue.
It's often what lab people use as a
substitute for the licking of the little
wrapped by the mother.
So,
so,
and he discovered the place circuit and
in mammals,
which is like a major deal,
right?
He should get a Nobel prize for that.
That's a big deal to discover an entire
motivational circuit whose existence no
one had really predicted,
you know,
apart from the fact that obviously
mammals play and uh,
even lizards,
maybe some of the more social lizard
seemed to play,
you know,
so anyhow,
but panksepp observed,
I think this is a brilliant piece of
science,
is that first of all,
juvenile male routes in particular,
like too rough and tumble play.
They like to wrestle and they actually
pin each other just like little kids do.
Or like adult wrestlers do.
They pin their shoulders down and that
basically means you win.
And so,
okay.
So that's pretty cool.
But what's even cooler,
I think while there's three things,
one is the rats will work for an
opportunity to get into an arena where
they know that play might occur,
and so that's one of the scientific ways
of testing in animals motivation,
right?
So imagine you have a starving route and
it knows that it's got food down the end
of a corridor.
You can put a little spring on its tail
and measure how hard it pulls and that
gives you an indication of it's
motivational force.
Now imagine the starving rat that's
trying to get to some food and you have
a little spring on his tail and you
walked in some cat odor.
So now that route is starving and wants
to get out of there.
He's going to try to pull even farther
towards the food.
So getting away plus getting forward are
separate motivational systems and if you
can add them together,
it's real potent.
And part of the reason why in the future
authoring exercise that you guys are
going to do as the class progresses,
you're asked to outline the place you'd
like to end up,
which is your desired future,
and also the place that you could end up
if you let everything fall apart is so
that your anxiety chases you and your
approach systems pull you forward.
You're maximally motivated,
dead,
and it's important because otherwise you
can be afraid of pursuing the things
that you want to pursue.
Right?
And that's very common.
And so then the fear inhibits you as the
promise pulls you forward,
but it makes you weak because you're
afraid.
You want to get your fear behind you,
pushing you.
And so what you want to be as afraid,
more afraid of not pursuing your goals
than you are of pursuing them.
It's very,
very helpful.
And lots of times in life,
and this is something really worth
knowing,
you know,
and this is one of the advantages to
being an autonomous adult,
is you don't get to pick the best thing.
You get to pick your poison.
You have two bad choices and you get to
pick which one you're willing to suffer
through and every choice has a bit of
that element in it,
and so if you know that,
it's really freeing because otherwise
you torture yourself by thinking,
well,
maybe there's a good solution to this.
You know,
compared to the bad solution.
It's like,
Nah,
Nah.
Sometimes there's just risky solution,
one and risky solution to and sometimes
both of them are really bad,
but you at least get to pick which one
you're willing to suffer through and
that's.
That actually makes quite a bit of
difference because you're also facing it
voluntarily then instead of chasing you,
and that is an entire different entirely
different psychophysiological response.
Challenge versus threat.
It's not the same.
Even if the magnitude of the problem is
the same,
and so putting yourself in a
challenging,
let's call it mind frame.
You can't just do that by magic.
Putting yourself in a challenging
mindframe is much,
much easier on you cycle physiologically
because you don't produce.
You don't go into the generalized stress
response to the same degree and you're
activating your exploratory and seeking
systems which are dopaminergic mediated
and that involved positive emotion.
So if you can face something voluntarily
rather than having to chase you,
it's way better for you cycle
physiologically.
So that's partly why.
Well,
it's worthwhile to go find the dragon in
its layer instead of waiting for it to
come and eat you.
So and especially when you also add the
idea that if you go find the dragon in
it's layer,
you might find it when it's a baby
instead of a full fledged bloody monster
that is definitely going to take you
down.
And so that's part of the reason why.
Well,
there's a whole bunch of things that,
that,
that emerge out of that observation,
like don't avoid small problems that you
know,
are there,
face them because they'll grow into big
problems all by themselves.
And you can think about,
imagine the Tax Department sends you a
notification.
You owe them like $300.
Well it's,
you know,
that's annoying.
Maybe you don't even want to open the
letter or maybe if you do,
you just put it on the shelf,
but that damn thing doesn't just sit
there like a piece of paper on the
shelf,
right?
You ignore that for five or six years.
It's going to be come attached to all
sorts of horrible things and if you
ignore it long enough,
you get the idea,
it's going to turn into something that
is completely unlike the little piece of
paper that it's written on and and many,
many problems in life are like that.
You'll see they'll,
you'll see that they popped their ugly
little head up and you know,
and you might want to turn away,
might not want not want to think about
it,
which is the easiest way of turning
away,
right?
You just don't attend to it.
It's not like you repress it or anything
like that.
You just failed to attend to it and
that's a really as a longterm strategy.
It's dismal.
It's also something that I think that's
more characteristic of people who are
high in neuroticism and high in
agreeableness.
Agreeable people don't like conflict and
people who were high in neuroticism,
we were high negative emotion are hit
harder per unit of uncertainty or
threat,
and so you know,
that's partly why in psychotherapy,
a lot of times the people you see need
assertiveness training,
so that would be the opposite of
agreeableness or they need to help get
their anxiety and emotional pain under
control.
It's.
Those are not the only reasons.
There's antisocial behavior,
but you can't fix that in therapy.
In all likelihood.
There's alcoholism,
there's lots and lots of other reasons,
but those are two major reasons.
So anyways,
there is a that was all to tell you
that.
Oh yes,
back to the rat.
So okay.
The rats are pulling on.
You can measure rat motivation by how
hard they pull on this on the spring,
let's say,
and they're more motivated if they're
running away and running towards,
but let's go back to play.
So you can take juvenile routes who
haven't been able to play for a while.
Maybe they've been isolated or maybe
they just haven't been able to engage in
physical activity like many school
children that you might be thinking
about,
um,
neither allowed to play nor allowed to
engage in physical activity.
And there's a reason I'm telling you
that.
So anyways,
you get one of these little rats and you
can measure all hardy wants,
how hard it,
he'll pull the go out and play or how
many buttons he'll push,
you know,
and that gives you an indication of his
motivation.
So anyways,
you can see that the play deprived
juvenile route will fight harder to play
than a non play deprived juvenile rat.
And so you can infer that the rat wants
to go play and uh,
you know,
you do that,
you do the same measurement with
everyone around you.
If they want to do something,
you're going to poke and prod out them
to see what sort of things they're
willing to overcome in order to go and
do.
You'll object even if you don't really
object.
It's like it's a measurement device.
And if they're willing to overcome a
bunch of your objections,
then you think,
oh well maybe they really want to.
And that's another thing to really know
if there's something you want,
you need about five arguments about why
you wanted,
because the probability that the person
who is opposing you will have five
arguments about why you shouldn't have
it,
is very low.
They just won't have thought it through
enough.
So the other thing that happens in the
future authoring exercises that you're
asked to articulate the reasons for all
the goals that come out of your vision
of the future.
So you're asked like why would it be
good for you?
Why would it be good for your family?
Why would it be good for broader
society?
And so that gives you the three levels
of argumentation right there.
And if you have it articulated down into
detail and it's related to other
important goals,
then you're,
you're a hell of a thing to argue with
because people just aren't that deep.
By which I mean they just don't have
that many levels of explanation or
objection.
And it's also really useful in
relationship to your own mind because if
you want to do something that's
difficult and that requires energy,
a lot of different subsystems in your
mind,
you're going to throw up objections.
It's like,
well,
maybe that isn't what you should be
doing right now.
Maybe you should be doing the dishes or
vacuuming or watching TV or looking at
youtube,
or if you're really sneaky,
when you're trying to do something hard,
what your brain does is give you
something else hard to do that's not
quite as hard so that you can feel
justified in not doing the thing you're
supposed to because you're doing
something else useful.
And if you give into that temptation,
which you often will,
then it winds and because it winds,
it gets a little dopamine kick and it
grows stronger.
Every anything you let when the internal
argument grows and anything you let be
defeated,
shrinks because it's punished.
It doesn't get to have its way.
So that's another thing really to
remember.
Don't practice what you do not want to
become.
And because those are their neurological
circuits,
you build those things in there.
Man,
they're,
they're not going anywhere.
You can build another little machine to
inhibit them.
That's the best you can do.
Once they're in there,
you can't get them out.
So.
And then the ones you build to inhibit
can be taken out by stress and the old
habits will come back up.
So you gotta be careful what you say and
what you do because you,
you build yourself that way.
So anyways,
back to the rats.
Okay?
So the little rat gets to go out there
and play.
Now imagine one little rat is paired
with another route,
but the little other little route is 10
percent.
Finger can percent in juvenile rats is
enough to obtain permanent dominant.
So that 10 percent bigger wrap will win
the first wrestling contest.
Okay?
And so that's what happens.
And then the.
So the little route gets pinned and
maybe they play a bit and then they're
done with it.
And so you separate them,
then you let them play again and the
next time what happens is that the
subordinate rat does the invitation to
play and that's like,
you know,
like a dog does when it wants to play.
You can recognize that kind of displays
its feet apart and it up and looks
interested in sort of dances around.
And you can do with any kid that has a
clue,
you know,
that hasn't been destroyed by adults.
If you little three year old kid or four
year olds are better for this.
If you go like this,
they know exactly what's going to
happen,
you know they're ready to dart back and
forth and they'll usually smile and,
and kids love rough and tumble play,
which is now basically illegal in all
daycares.
It seriously,
it seriously is it.
Kids need it so desperately because it
teaches them the limits of their body
and your body and it teaches them what's
painful and what isn't.
And it teaches them the dance of play.
And without that they're just little
disembodied blobs like they have no
finance.
What?
That's what you're checking out when you
dance with someone you know you're
seeing if they have that,
that fluency and facility for mutual
reciprocal action in embodied in them,
and if they're kind of like this,
you know and just have no sense of
rhythm and don't pay any attention to
you and all of that.
You have reason to question whether they
actually inhabit their body and whether
they can engage in a mutual interaction,
the physical interaction that's going to
be reciprocal and mutually satisfying.
It's really important to check out and a
lot of that rough and tumble play.
Even interactions between a child and
it's mother.
If you have a happy mother and unhappy
infant and you videotape them and you
speed up the video tape,
you'll see that they're dancing.
So one response than the other response
than the other responds.
It might just be with eye-gaze and
movement and all of that,
but there's a dynamic interplay which
you don't see with depressed mothers and
their infants.
So okay,
so back to play.
So the little rat who got is the
subordinate one.
He has to do the invitation and then the
big rat can allow agreed to play because
he's in the dominant position,
but if you pair them repeatedly,
and this is really we're thinking about,
because see,
morality emerges out of repeated
interactions because you might say,
well,
if you're only interact with someone
wants,
he might as well just take advantage of
them and run off.
That's what a psychopath does by the
way.
And there is,
there is room in an environmental niche
for psychopaths,
but they have to keep moving around
because otherwise people figure out who
they are so they just move around and
they can take advantage of one person,
you know,
maybe five times or 10 times or
something,
and then the reputation spreads and they
gotta get the hell out of there.
But so it's not a good longterm strategy
unless you can't think of a better one.
So anyways,
if you repeatedly pair these routes,
unless the big rat lets the little rat
win,
at least 30 percent of the time,
the little rat will not ask the big rat
to play.
And that is,
it's a staggering discovery.
It's a staggering discovery because
you've got the emergence there of a of a
implicit morality essentially that's
even incarnated in rats that emerges
across multiple play sessions.
It's like,
yes,
exactly.
That's exactly what Piaget said about
the emergence of morality.
It's exactly the same idea at the right
level,
so it's.
It's a massively and the fact that
there's a circuit,
a separate neurophysiological circuit
that's actually specialized for that
sort of thing is also a big deal.
Now,
the other thing banks have figured out
is that if you deprive juvenile rats
have the opportunity to engage in rough
and tumble play,
their prefrontal cortex is don't develop
properly and they become impulsive and
restless and then you can fix them with
methylphenidate or Ritalin and those are
the drugs that are used to fix
hyperactive kids,
most of whom are male,
and that's because,
well really you're going to take your
six year old,
your five year old,
you know,
put them in a desk.
You're going to get them to sit there
for six hours.
That's your plan,
right?
That's a stupid plan and there they are,
denied the opportunity to engage in play
and that means that their ability to
become social is being impaired.
It may cause neurological impairment.
That's what the evidence suggests and
then you suppress that within fed means
because amphetamines actually don't
activate the play circuit.
They activate a different circuit which
will suppress the place.
So it's very,
very.
It's not very wise and I'm not going to
go off on that tangent because I
couldn't tell you why this school
systems were set up that way,
which I probably will at some point
because it's quite an interesting story
in and of itself and it's the reason all
you guys are sitting in desks right now.
Somebody laughingly referred to this one
says Grade Fifteen,
which I thought was pretty funny given
the look at the bloody place,
you know,
a hideous and so now this is an
interesting thing.
So you've got the emergence of morality
and say,
chimps,
you've got the emergence of morality and
wolves.
He got the emergence of morality and
rats and the morality governs sequential
interactions or group interactions.
They have to repeat because.
Because it's an emergent property of
social or repetitive interactions and
that's why you can't just localize it in
one instance to repeat it and uh,
there's been computer simulations of
this too,
to help you figure out how you might
attain victory across games across time.
Maybe you need a strategy and that
there's a very simple strategy which I
believe is called modified tit for tat.
So if you're nice to me,
I'm nice back and if you do something
bad to me,
I do something bad back.
But,
but imagine you run that out in
sequences of a behavior and see who who
does best with what strategy across time
or an alternative strategy.
Here's the best strategy.
I trust you.
You Trust me,
we start interacting,
you screw up,
I whack you and then I forgive you.
And we started getting that's modified,
tit for tat.
And so,
and there hasn't been an issue.
It's a very simple algorithm.
No one has come up with a better
algorithm in computer game,
in,
in the computerized simulation of game
space that not particular strategy.
So it's like trust,
but don't be a pushover if someone
violates the rules,
you've got to nail them,
but then you don't hold grudge.
He opened the door to further
interactions.
So pretty smart,
pretty smart and okay.
So anyways,
so what this means,
because rats can't talk,
can't talk and chimpanzees can't talk.
And what that means,
just as piaget suggested,
was that the morality,
the development of the morality precedes
the development of the linguistic
ability to describe the rules for the
morality.
He said exactly the same thing about
kids,
right?
As they learn how to play games before
they know how,
what the rules are to the games and so
you see that with your playing peekaboo
with a kid who they can pick that up
like really young to get that right away
and there's.
You can play with kids almost
immediately after they're born if you
play simple enough games and so they've
got that deep and they're unbelievably
playful.
So they've got that circuitry ready to
go right off the bat.
And it's one of the things that makes
kids so much fun because they just liked
to play all the time.
And so if you're,
if the play circuit and you hasn't died,
which is a bad thing,
then you can use that a lot with your
kids.
And it's one of the things that helps
you love them.
So that's a good thing.
So okay,
so the point is that the dam morality
emerges before the representation of the
morality.
It's a big deal to know that and that it
emerges as a consequence of repeated
social interaction.
So it's not a top down thing.
It's a bottom up thing.
Now with Piaget says,
well,
it's not just bottom up because what
happens with human beings is that they
learn to play the games.
His one of his experiments was watched
seven year olds,
I think that's the right age,
play marbles.
And then you notice that they can play
with each other and that they can follow
the rules.
But then if you take the individual
seven year olds out of the game and you
say,
what are the rules?
They give incoherent and incomplete
explanations of the rules,
so what that means is they've it don't
really represent the rules,
but they can act them out and they have
a partial representation of what they're
acting out.
Now when they get older,
the rural representation starts to fall
into alignment with the actual rules of
the game and you can imagine that's why
because when they're playing something
like marbles,
they're going to have discussions like
your treat,
your cheating or you're not allowed to
do that because they're always going to
be pushing the envelope a little bit and
then the group is going to render a
judgment on whether or not that's
appropriate and out of that,
the rules are going to emerge,
but they're not rules to begin with
their patterns of behavior.
It's not the same thing as a rule.
A rule describes a pattern of behavior,
but a pattern of behavior.
He has a pattern of behavior.
It's something that's acted out,
so there's the individual within the
group and then the interactions of the
individuals within the groups produces a
hierarchical arrangement or multiple
hierarchical arrangements.
Those are games,
roughly speaking or stories nested
inside an overarching story,
which is the fundamental culture,
right?
And then that's nested in a whole bunch
of competing cultures that have some
commonalities or they would just be at
war all the time,
which you know,
to some degree they are.
So now you see that back to the movie,
you see that happening in this movie.
I mean it's very,
very quick.
But the,
the um,
the blue fairy terns the bug into the
conscience and then the bug tries to
explain to Pinocchio what the rules of
morality are.
But the thing is the bug doesn't know
because he's just a bug and you know,
he,
he's,
he's just not omniscient.
So the best he can do is to come up with
like a propaganda stick,
semantic verbal representation that's
internally contradictory.
And when he tells Pinocchio,
Pinocchio has no idea what he's talking
about and neither does the bug.
That's the thing.
And so,
well,
so what happens is this,
that the cricket says,
well pinnock maybe you and I had better,
have a little heart to heart talk and a
puppet says y.
and the cricket says,
well you want to be a real boy,
don't you?
Alright,
sit down son.
Now you see the world is full of
temptations.
Temptations,
yes.
Temptations.
There the wrong things that seem right
at the time.
But even though the right things may
seem wrong sometimes,
sometimes the,
the wrong things maybe right at the
wrong time or vice versa,
understand.
No,
no.
And needed to cricket and,
and,
and that's actually very nicely done in
that piece of the movie because as soon
as you just want to slap him as soon as
he starts talking like that,
because while he gets up on his little
matchbox and lectures and he's dull and
tyrannical both at the same time.
And so there's nothing genuine about
what he's saying.
He's sort of imitating.
He's imitating something that isn't him.
So he's really acting like a puppet at
that point too.
And it doesn't work at all.
And so Pinocchio says,
I'm going to try to be a good boy.
And the cricket says,
well that's,
that's the spirit son.
And then away they go.
So all right,
so then we're at the next day because
this all happens in one night.
We're at the next day and you know,
it's a nice day and there's these birds
flying around.
That's actually,
that's a bit of foreshadowing there.
You know,
so I'm not really.
You have to remember when you watch
something like this movie,
not a single bit of it is random or
accidental.
None of it because you know they had to
draw.
I don't remember how many frames per
second these things are 30.
Maybe.
Maybe it's a little less than that,
but it's high quality automation and so
someone had to paint 30 pictures to get
a second of this.
You're not doing that accidentally.
It's really expensive and everyone has
to agree on exactly what's going to
happen.
And you might say,
well do the people who are doing this
consciously know what they're doing?
And the answer to that is,
well,
sort of just like you do you know it's
yes,
they no,
no they don't.
And they know because they're really
smart and gifted and all that,
but they don't know because it's not all
articulated.
Plus,
they're working in a group so they know
and don't know just like you do when
you're watching it and so and when you
do anything else,
so now they're also guided by what you
might call they're guided by their
unconscious in the in the Freudian and
in the cognitive way,
partly because your unconscious value
structures determine the direction and
content of your perceptions and so it's
built right into the way you move your
eyes because you tend to look at things
you value right or things you're afraid
of,
like you look at things with valence and
part of the decision about what has
value is dependent on the implicit
structure of your moral system,
your purse,
because morality is about what's good
and what isn't,
and that's been partly a conscious
construction of you,
but it's partly something you've been.
You've picked up by interacting with
people like mad ever since you were
born.
You don't know all the rules anymore
than the damn cricket did.
You just don't and you can't because
you're too complicated,
but you act them out and then you also
have representations of how people act
in your imagination.
Dreams are.
That's what a dream is.
That's what a fantasy is.
That's what that little movie that plays
inside your head when you remember what
you did is,
and you only remember the just you know,
so even the the images stick
representation of your behavior in your
past,
which is basically your episodic memory.
It's already selecting and molding and
turning it into a relatable story.
It can't help but do that.
It's the only way you can represent it
and so you don't know how you do that or
why you do that,
but part of it's governed by this
implicit morality that's part of your
procedural memory system.
Part of the way you act and part of the
way you move your eyes and listen to
things and focus on them and that's all
been instantiated inside of you because
of this immense social,
your biology,
but also this immense social project
that you're continually engaged in and
so that informs what you remembered.
It informs what you imagined.
It informs what we collectively imagine.
It informs what we can collectively
understand and partly what you're doing
well,
you become conscious of yourself is to
map the implicit structures that already
constitute you from society into
explicit representation.
That's what self understanding means and
you know when you have that moment of
insight about something you've done,
it's like you're watching your this
repetitive behavior that you've
manifested probably that got you in
trouble.
You know it's your characteristic way of
falling accidentally into chaos and you
talk about your problems.
You talk about them with your friends,
you talk about them and maybe you have
dreams about them and you're,
you're trying to relate them and you
have memories about them that you can't
get rid of because they're negatively
tones.
So you talk about them and then someone
comes up with a little statement that
links them together,
causley and he thank God that's what I'm
doing.
And then maybe you can stop doing it or
at least,
or at least maybe.
Then you can think of some strategies
for not doing it anymore,
but it's not like,
you know,
it's like you're acting it out,
you know it that way,
but until that's until the
representation matches that pattern,
that click of insight doesn't occur and
that's like a revelation.
It's a really good way of thinking about
it because the knowledge is there and
it's implicit forum and all of a sudden
bang.
It's been made explicit as a fantasy
maybe or also as a,
as a set of semantic statements.
You know,
maybe you're,
you have a crush on someone and you
don't notice it and maybe you find
yourself having a fantasy about him.
You Think,
oh,
that means something that indicates
something.
Maybe you don't want to know that that's
what you want.
But the fantasy will tell you.
And one of the things you suggested,
and this is sort of out of the Freudian
tradition of free associations,
is watch yourself.
Watch your fantasies because they're
always happening and so,
and they'll tell you something.
And so one of the things I do when when
I'm interacting with my clients is we'll
have a discussion and then they'll let
their eyes will drift a little bit and
I'll know that there,
that something's flitted through their
mind,
you know,
and that means we've touched on
something that has multiple,
a multiplicity of elements.
And so I'll stop and say,
look,
I noticed that you maybe you tear it up.
That's another thing to really watch
her.
Maybe you laugh or you drifted.
At least it's like it's because some
other thought has entered your field of
consciousness.
And then if you can get the person to
grab those thoughts,
to notice them,
then you can often figure out the
avenues along which that particular
conversation might unfold.
That's a complex,
that's a union complex or a
psychoanalytic complex.
It's like there's an emotional core that
produces a whole range of associated
ideas and that thing's got a life.
It's like a micro personality and it
might have resentment and it might have
anger.
It's often negative emotion tinge
because the negative emotion tinge
episodes are still problems and they
will emerge automatically because your
threat detection systems force them onto
your consciousness essentially so you
watch and where when you drift you will
drift and the fantasy is partly a
representation of the problem space.
You know that happens when you wake up
at three in the morning and you're
worried about things,
right?
Because actually what happens is you
wake up during threat processing and if
you're depressed actually that gets so
intense you can't sleep,
so then you just lay there all night
worrying,
not fun,
and those are fantasies about the
negative elements of your past,
present and future,
and the fantasies can also breed
solutions.
And that's partly why Freud regarding
dreams as wish fulfillment.
It's partly that and he wasn't.
That was where he stopped.
It's not correct.
It,
it's partially correct.
It's like the fantasy will provide you
with a problem and a potential solution,
but they're more like problem
identification mechanisms.
The fantasies with the possibility of a
solution built in.
And so a way of thinking about that is
that you can generate potential futures,
so they're like each segregated
environments according to the rules of
your fantasy.
Then you can generate little avatars of
yourself that didn't have at each of
those little universes and you can run
them as simulations and then you can
watch what happens in the simulation and
if it's a catastrophe,
then you don't have to act it out.
And that's exactly not exactly.
That's akin to what you're doing when
you go watch a movie,
except that is much more coherent and
well thought through.
And then just a dream which is often
quite fragmentary.
And that's partly because of the dream
is willing to sacrifice coherence to
play with category structures,
you know?
And that's why in dreams things can
change from one thing into another.
Really weirdly or scenes can change from
one scene to another without a logic.
The logic gets loosened so that the
experience of your thinking can widen
and it's,
it's not.
It's dangerous to do that.
And that's partly why you do it.
When you're asleep and paralyzed,
you don't run around and act out your,
your suit,
a puddle fantasies,
you know where you're stretching
yourself out into the world.
There is no risk.
Exactly and so although it can be bad
enough so you'll wake up in terror,
you know,
but that's better than being in a
crocodile's mouth by a large margin.
Anyways,
back to these,
these birds,
these are used later in the movie as a
manifestations of the holy spirit,
roughly speaking,
and of course that's a standard
Christian symbol.
Although as I mentioned,
the dove often represents the holy
spirit and we'll talk about that later,
but this movie has very strong pagan
elements in it,
as I mentioned before,
as opposed to a strictly Christian
symbolism.
But,
but that's a foreshadowing.
And what it foreshadows is that while a
new day has dawned,
it's the emergence of new consciousness
and everything last night went well
really well.
Everything in the,
let's call it the unconscious say,
after time stops,
that all went well and so the new day is
full of promise and so the birds are
singing in,
the sun is shining and like hooray.
And so that's exactly so that sets.
This is the next scene,
right?
So it sets the tenor for that scene just
like the introductory song does.
So.
So anyways.
Then you see all these kids playing and
enthusiastic so they're off to school
which is presented in a positive light
and so that's where you get socialized
is Pinocchio is ready to go beyond the
boundaries of the familial home and he's
ready because his father prepared amend
because his mother prepared and so he
goes off and he's not going off alone.
He's going with his conscience and which
is sort of the Internet.
You could think about it again as the
internalized representation of nature
and society and so he's not going out
there alone even though he's not very
good at it.
And he's pretty excited about this.
And so is Japan.
See Japan is standing there paralyzed
with terror and the kid isn't phobic of
the outside world and so that's,
he's,
he's right.
He's treating it as an adventure.
I mean,
even though,
well,
it's an adventure,
but adventure's can be dangerous.
What if the other,
you can imagine a kid,
especially one who's like high in
neuroticism,
who hasn't been encouraged sufficiently
to overcome that?
Let's say their primary idea might be,
well,
what if the other kids don't like me?
That's a big one.
What if the teachers don't like me?
What if the other kids won't play with
me?
It's like,
yeah,
what if that's rough man?
And if,
if you're not a playful kid,
it could easily be the case.
So,
but that's not Pinocchio.
He's like spinning out,
ready to go.
And so good.
Good.
He's got naive but enthusiastic.
Okay,
well that at least gets the ball
rolling.
Now you've got these two evil creatures
here,
the Fox and the cat.
Um,
I think this one's based on one of the
Marx brothers,
actually Harpo Marx,
who I believe never said anything,
but be that as it may.
There are these Ne'er do well
characters,
um,
the Fox in particular,
now fox is a standard trickster animal,
right?
It's a,
it's a,
it's,
it's a classic animal.
Maybe because it's good at hiding and
it's good at hunting.
I don't know exactly why,
but it's,
and coyotes are like that too.
They're classic trickster animals.
Um,
he's Kinda like Wiley Coyote,
in fact,
you know,
the,
the warner brothers character whose
genius at large and of course whose
arrogance continually gets him walloped
and this character has a lot of features
like that,
but he,
he's,
he feigns being,
uh,
an English gentleman of the 18 nineties
and pretends to be educated and,
and,
uh,
it has our kind of high blown way of
talking and he's a fraud through and
through and he's got,
he's got this,
you know,
sidekick who is barely there at all and
he doesn't treat him that well,
but he's got someone to Lord it over.
So that keeps his dominance hierarchy
thing going well.
And the fact that he's like a second
rate companion while he never really
noticed is that although he'll treat him
contemptuously whenever he gets a
chance.
So anyways,
they're walking down the street and,
uh,
the,
Fox is bragging away about some crooked
thing that he's done and how he pulled
the wool over someone's eyes.
And he confuses that with a wisdom and
intelligence.
And one of the things that you see this
is worth knowing too,
because if you're preyed upon by a
psychopath,
which you will be to some degree at some
point in your life,
the psychopath who will be narcissistic
will presume that you're stupid and,
and,
and that you deserve to be taken
advantage of because you're naive and
stupid.
So it's actually a good thing that he's
doing it.
And,
uh,
he,
his proof for,
and I'm saying he,
because there are more male psychopaths,
um,
the,
uh,
the proof that you're stupid naive is
that he can take advantage of you.
And so like if you were wiser you,
you'd be,
you know,
you'd,
you'd know his tricks and then it
wouldn't be morally necessary for him to
show you just exactly who knows what
about what.
And so the psychopath will use his
ability to fool you as proof of his own
grandiose,
grandiose omnipotence,
omniscience and narcissism.
And the problem with that is that you
can be fooled by a psychopath and
virtually anybody can.
So that Robert Hare,
for example,
who studied psychopaths for a long time
and interviewed a lot of them,
like hundreds of them and videotape many
of the interviews he said when he was
talking to the psychopath,
he always believed what they were
saying.
And then he'd watched the video
afterwards and see where the
conversation went off the rails.
But you know,
the pro,
the proclivity to be polite in a
conversation is very strong.
And if you're polite,
you don't object to the way that the
person unfolds their strategy.
You know?
And psychopaths are pretty good at
figuring out how to manipulate
obviously,
how to manipulate people and the
probability that you will be immune to
that is extraordinarily low.
Go Watch Paul Bernardo being interviewed
by policemen on,
on Youtube.
That's bloody.
That's enlightening man.
Paul Bernardo,
he's like the CEO of a meeting in that
video,
you know,
he gives the cops hell.
It gives lawyers hell.
He protested his innocence.
He basically tells them that they're
rude and untrustworthy because they
don't trust him because he did a few
little things 17 years ago and he gets
away with it.
A few little things,
right?
I mean,
he killed a bunch of people,
including the sister of his girlfriend
at the time and you know,
he was a repeat sexual offender and
murderer.
It's like,
but he basically goes,
well,
you know,
that's a long time ago.
It's like we're,
we're past that,
aren't we?
I mean,
I'm having a discussion with you.
I'm trying to solve help you solve some
crimes,
which by the way,
I committed,
but we won't bring that up.
You know,
and you're,
you're,
you're accusing me of being a liar,
like you're not playing fair what,
what's up with you?
And then when they answer,
he looks at his fingernails,
which is like,
that's a lovely little manipulative
thing because it basically means
whatever happens to be under my
fingernail at the moment is much higher
priority than listening to your story
and you watch,
you'll see people do that to you and
then you get a little insight into what
they're up to.
He's very good at that and so.
Or he looks outside or,
or are you just looking at his hands?
He looks out the window immediately.
Dismissive and his nonverbal behavior
pr.
It's brilliant that the courts were
forced to release that by the way,
but look it up,
Paul Bernardo on Youtube.
Wow.
It's,
it's just mind boggling.
It's he's so good at what he does and
he's good looking and he's charismatic
and he can really pull it off and you
can't tell what's happening with the
cops and the lawyers,
whether they're just letting him play as
a routine to get some information from
them or whether he's actually setting
them back on his heels.
And I suspect it's a bit of both,
but it's a masterful performance.
If you didn't know who he was and you
were watching it without the audio,
you'd think he's the CEO of some company
given its employees hell for not being
up to scratch.
That's all his body language,
his eye contact,
everything just speaks to that.
It's amazing.
So anyways,
you've got these two bit hoods here who
think they're really something.
They also think they're tough and
dangerous and and they're not.
They're just cowardly and cornered
dwellers.
And,
and they confuse their unwillingness to
abide by reasonable rules as indication
of their heroic courage,
which is something else that low rent
hoods like to do.
You know?
And it's partly because lots of people
who just attend to the law do do that
because they're cowardly,
which is a Nietzschean observation.
Are you good?
Are you just afraid?
Let's start with afraid first before we
proceed to good.
And that the reason that you follow the
rules is because you're afraid of
getting caught.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
those kids who I often university kids
who are in like a hockey riot and they
ended up breaking windows and stealing
things and you know,
they get nailed for it and afterwards
they're really blown away by their own
behavior.
It's like,
well they're in that camp.
It's like they think they're good
people,
but they're not.
They're just never anywhere where you
could be bad.
And as soon as you put them somewhere
where they could be bad,
it's like,
would it comes just like that?
And that's,
that's really worth thinking about
because most of you,
many of you but not all of you,
I suspect have never really been
somewhere that you could be really bad
and get away with it.
And so you might think,
well,
you wouldn't do it,
but,
but people do it all the time.
So anyways,
they're talking about some exploits and
then they see that this character named
Stromboli who's a Marionette,
he has a puppet show,
right?
And uh,
he's kind of a wheeler dealer to
remember you.
I showed you that,
that mask that was glaring out Pinocchio
when he got his voice,
it's like Stromboli isn't one of his
manifestations.
These Fox here is another one of his
manifestations and all of the negative
characters throughout the movie are
manifestations of the same thing.
It's partly the adversarial individual
and it's partly the theoretical aspect
of society.
It's the negative masculine that's,
that's one way of thinking about it.
So,
and you know,
when men go bad,
they often go bad by being antisocial
and tyrannical.
So where there's way more antisocial men
than are anti social women,
which is why there's 20 times as many
men in jail as there are women.
So each gender,
let's say each sex has its own path,
characteristic pathologies.
And there are some antisocial women,
you know,
and,
and there are some high neuroticism guys
who are,
or some guys who are really agreeable as
well,
so,
but they're rarer.
So anyways,
he sees this,
this a poster advertising strombolis
puppet show.
So strombolis a puppet master.
Now that's really worth thinking about
because that's an archetypal theme or
it's at least attached to an
architectural theme.
Some things behind the scenes pulling
the strings.
And everybody always wonders what that
is.
Right?
What's actually going on?
What's actually going on with trump?
Who's actually in control?
Is it Putin?
I mean,
that's,
that's the,
that's the fantasies of the left.
It's potent.
It's like,
well,
the question always is what's going on
behind the seed?
Right?
And the question is,
that's the case,
certainly on the political landscape,
the business landscape,
interpersonal relations,
what,
what are you really up to?
Everyone's always wondering that right
there.
That's why they're watching your eyes
because your eyes pointed things and
they can infer what you're interested
in.
And then what you're up to by looking at
what you look at.
And that's why your eyes have whites is
so that we can see where you're pointing
because gorillas don't.
And so,
so what that means roughly speaking,
is that all of your ancestors whose eyes
couldn't be reliably tracked were either
killed or didn't mate.
It's a big deal for us to see where
people's eyes are pointed.
And so we're always watching each
other's eyes constantly.
What are you up to?
What are you looking at?
What do you want?
And I want to know because if I know
what you want,
I can predict how you're going to behave
and that also means I can cooperate with
you or I can compete with you or I can
lie to you,
but all the information is in the eyes
of surrounded by the facial display,
right?
Because that's also an indication of
motivation and emotion.
And so we're trying like our eyes are so
good at that.
But for you guys sitting there in the
back,
I can tell if you're looking at my eyes
or at my Chin and the deviation in your
eyes is so tiny that it's.
It's a kind of miracle that we're
capable of making that perceptual
observation,
so really important to us.
So.
And we have really good eyes.
So that's another thing about us.
So anyways,
what's going on behind the scenes?
Well,
if you look at Stromboli,
you might be thinking it's not clear he,
someone you'd want to have pulling your
strings,
like there's a little bit of forced
enthusiasm,
let's say there.
And he's just not a very savory look and
character.
So anyways,
the Fox knows them and they start
talking about Stromboli.
That'll joker and then what they could,
how they could possibly involve hidden
in him in some sort of scam because he's
back in town and then they see the
puppet and the Fox does his equivalent
of thinking,
which is,
you know,
pretty sad but,
and nasty,
but that's what he does.
And then they see this puppet with no
strings and they think,
hey man,
a puppet master would pay a lot for
something that is capable of semi
autonomous movement like that.
It would be kind of a miracle.
And so they decided that they're going
to take them to Stromboli.
And so they grab them and he's,
he's got an apple to take to the
teacher,
which I think it's the cat promptly eats
and uh,
that the FARC saw acts out this sort of
false enthusiasm about what Pinocchio is
up to and pretends that he's his friend,
which is of course what your typical
pedophile will do.
And so this is in the same kind of
category and it truly is.
So one of the things that's to know
about pedophiles and is that they're
predatory,
right?
And so they don't go after kids that are
assertive and likely to be noisy.
They watch and they watch to see if they
can find a kid who's defeated and that's
good enough who's defeated and who is
going to need a friend and who's not
going to object.
And so when they check out,
these are the ones who do the stranger
abductions,
which are,
by the way extraordinarily rare.
They look for a victim type.
They look for a kid who's going to be
easy to take down.
And so,
you know,
that's one thing you don't want.
So you might think,
well,
one of the things that was really big
and it's probably even worse now when I
was a parent of young children,
was to teach your kids how to be afraid
of strangers.
It's like a no wrong id.
That is not what you teach them because
all you do is teach the men to be timid
and fearful and the real predatory types
there are,
there are pretty much thrilled about
that because you'll also make them
sheltered and naive,
you know,
so that is you make your kids courageous
and you get the damn eyes open and
that's the best thing you can do to
protect them against people who are
truly dangerous.
So none of that terrifying that it's not
a good idea.
Anyways,
they,
the,
the Fox befriends the puppet,
and then they come up with this evil
scheme to get them off to Stromboli,
the puppet master and the way they go
and they sing a little song about being
an actor,
an actor's life.
For me,
and this took me a long time to figure
out,
I thought they're taking Pinocchio away
to be an actor.
Now why in the world are actors getting
such a rough time in this movie?
It's like it's a Hollywood movie,
you know,
it's acting obviously the voiceovers and
all that are acting.
It's why.
What is this thing about being an actor?
And then I thought,
oh,
I get it.
I see what's going on that they seem to
Pinocchio about the delights of unearned
celebrity.
So He's,
he's doesn't have to go and get an
education.
He doesn't have to take the difficult
route.
He can take the easy way to dominance,
to success,
two dominant success.
He can circumvent all the hard work and
go right to the top,
you know,
and when you think about phenomena like
the Kardashians family and how popular
they are,
part of that is this desire that people
have for unearned celebrity because you
can get to the top without any
sacrifices and without any work.
And if you're really cynical,
you know,
you think that the people at the top are
just there by accident anyways and it
might as well be you.
And of course there's a lot of naivety
in that as well.
And,
and a fair bit of,
you know,
not a fair lack of wisdom and all of
that,
but the actor idea here is that you can,
you can pretend to be something you're
not and that that's the proper route of
anyone wise to success.
It's the ultimate and cynicism and it's
a nihilistic perspective as well and
that's how they interact and they say,
look,
why are you going?
Why are you bothering to go to school?
That's going to take 18 years with all
of your talents.
You can just go on the stage,
your name will be up in lights,
you'll be out the top and no time.
And what is the puppet?
No.
And plus he does have some talents.
He is after all,
a semi autonomous puppet.
Now he doesn't exactly know how special
that makes them,
but the Fox can obviously see something
in him and he's good at playing that,
naive it often in offering these false
promises.
But see,
the thing is one of the things that Carl
Jung said that I thought was really
interesting when he was talking about
the whole situation and families.
I never forgot this,
so the eatables situation,
roughly speaking is when I'll lay out
the classic story is when a child is
seriously overprotected,
usually a male child by his mother.
Now the reverse can be the case and it
can be a female child by the mother and
all of that,
but I'll just talk about the classic
case to begin with.
Now what Freud observed was that there
were usually not very good boundaries in
families like that and so the
relationship between the husband and the
wife was either strange or nonexistent
and the wife would often turn to the
child to be what she isn't getting from
the husband,
and so there's a great south park
episode about this,
a wonderful south park episode where
they were.
I don't remember that horrible little
guy.
Is that.
That's him.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And his mother brings in the dog
whisperer to train him and it's
brilliant.
It's brilliant episode.
If you want to learn about Freudian,
Freudian eatable situation,
you,
you watch that.
You've got it down cold because she
brings in this expert who then she wants
to have an affair with.
So that's a boundary issue and he
basically separates her son from him
and,
and imposes the same discipline on him
that he would do impose on a bad dog,
although he also trains the dogs owners
all the time because maybe it's not the
dog,
maybe it's the owner.
There's a horse whisperer movie too,
about the original horse whisperer that
does a beautiful job of laying that out
too because he's very good at fixing
problem horses and unbelievably good at
diagnosing psychopathology on the part
of the owner.
It's his,
he's got a gift for it.
But anyways,
what happens in this South Park episode
is that the dog whisperer gets cartland
yeah,
straightened out and he starts like
dressing properly and doing his
homework.
And,
and the mother is pursuing an affair
with the dog whisperer,
but he's professionally keeps his
distance,
like he keeps boundaries around them.
And uh,
then he leaves.
And then the first thing that she does
when he leaves his bride cartman
basically out of doing his homework so
that he can accompany her to know a fast
food restaurant or something like that.
And so the reason she does that is
because she's lonesome and it doesn't
have anybody else around and you know,
maybe she's also deeply,
deeply,
deeply terrified that if she helps that
boy grow,
he will leave and she'll have nothing,
you know.
And so mothers who don't have something
say outside their infants,
not merely their children are more
likely to fall into that.
And it's no wonder,
you know,
you got to think that through.
And lots of women really,
most women really fall in love with
their babies,
you know.
And so even if they start growing into
larger children,
that can be threatening because,
well,
when the,
when the child turns into,
when the infant turns into a toddler
that the infant is dead,
there's the toddler is there now and you
can radically interfere with that
process.
That happens all the time,
all the time.
That's the classic Freudian eatable
nightmare.
And that episode is brilliant.
It's bloody brilliant.
It just nails it.
And some of you have been in my
personality class and watched crumb the
documentary crum.
And that's another staggering exposition
of exactly that kind of pathology.
Anyways,
one of the things young pointed out,
so I knew this guy wants who had a
mother who basically was trying that
trick and she had lots of.
She was very smart and had lots of
tricks up our sleeves and there's just
no way he was going to go for it.
He rebelled at every possible moment and
he basically became,
I would say,
somewhat hypermasculine in response,
which is a,
which is an interesting lesson with
regards to the hypermasculinity that
boys often develop if they're raised by
single mothers because they tend to go
one of two ways and he just fought her
at every step of the way and it didn't
happen.
But one of the things you said,
which I loved,
and you can really see this in the
chrome documentary,
is that the oedipal mother basically
entices.
The child says,
look,
here's the deal.
You don't have to do anything but you
don't get to leave.
But if you don't leave and you don't do
these difficult things,
then I'll take care of you.
And the child has a choice all the way
along there.
I mean,
obviously he's outclassed in some sense,
but it's not as obvious as you'd think
little kids are tough and they make
decisions all the time and so young
thought about it more as a conspiracy
than as something imposed on the child
by the mother.
And I really like.
It's actually a conspiracy between
mother,
father and child actually.
And I think that's a good way of looking
at it even though it's really rough
because said,
well,
should you hold a child responsible?
Well,
yes,
but judiciously and not completely
because then if you deal with someone
like that as an adult and they're trying
to escape from it,
you have to go all the way back and
figure out how the hell it happened.
And then they have to adjust.
They have to figure out where they
opened the door,
like inviting a vampire in because they
can't come in unless you invite them in,
you know,
so don't invite them in because once
they're in,
they're really hard to get rid of and
they'll take all your blood.
So that's a cautionary tale.
So anyways,
Pinocchio doesn't know any better and
he's got the egotism of,
you know,
of youth and he's offered the easy way
to success,
which is exactly what the Fox tells them
and off they go to see Stromboli.
So this is the song,
I'm not going to read it all.
It's great to be a celebrity and actor's
life for me.
Um,
sleep till after to you promenade a big
cigar,
you tour the world in a private car,
you dine on chicken and caviar and
actor's life for me.
So it's all this idea of,
of wealth and public exposure and zero
attention whatsoever to anything
regarding responsibility or discipline
or learning.
And so it's a dual attraction,
right?
You get everything we want and you don't
have to do anything.
Jesus,
what a deal.
And so that's what the act or
represents.
It's,
it's a liar.
Fundamentally,
it's someone who's acting out a,
a deception there,
a persona in the union sense.
So the persona is the mask you wear in
public that you might even think you
are,
but you're not.
It's this mask and that's the act.
That's the persona.
So the Fox and the cat or inviting the
puppet to only become a persona and and
that's,
that's see for young,
you start as a persona and then when you
start to investigate the parts of you
that don't really fit in that persona,
that would be the shadow.
Then you start understanding who you
really are and that's shocking because
the persona contains everything roughly
speaking that you think is good and
maybe even that your immediate culture
thinks is good and then the shadow
contains everything that's not part of
that and some of that's really bad,
but some of it is good,
disguised as bad,
and you can't break out of the persona
and transcended until you incorporate a
lot of what's in the shadow.
And so for example,
if you're an extraordinarily
compassionate person,
let's say 98th percentile will say
you're going to be sacrificing yourself
to other people all the time and there
are people who will find that
extraordinarily endearing and it will be
under some circumstances.
But the problem is is that you will
sacrifice yourself and that's a really
bad attitude to have.
For example,
towards adult males.
It's a great thing for infants,
but for adult males it is the wrong
approach and so you will get taken
advantage of continually by people who
are looking for someone like you until
you grow some teeth and you'll think,
no,
no.
That's the opposite of compassion.
Being able to bite hard is the opposite
of compassion,
which it is,
and so you'll have that pushed into the
predatory category.
I'm not doing that.
I'm not getting angry.
I don't like conflict.
It's like until you bring that out of
the depths and put it on so you can use
it,
you're going to be in trouble and that's
kind of niches,
idea of the reevaluation of good and
evil,
right?
You have a sense of what's good in a
sense of what isn't with your
conscience,
but it's not very smart.
It's got things in the wrong boxes and a
lot of the things that even nature
itself,
a lot of the things that you accept as
untrammeled goods like compassion,
let's say have a very dark side first of
all and are not enough to get you
through life.
You need the opposite virtues to and so
you have to develop them and so you get
outside the persona to do that,
but anyways,
Pinocchio was invited to be a false
persona,
to take the gains of celebrity without
having to do anything to be educated.
He's just going to go right to the top
from right where he is and you know
people are kind of fascinated by that
idea.
That's why you watch America's got
talent or the x factor with your shows.
I actually love,
by the way you.
You never see narcissism in its pure
forms.
Then you see it when you watch people
who display an absolute lack of talent
and become homicidal.
When someone dares pointed out,
right,
accusatory and homicidal instantly,
it's really something,
and then now and then you do see one of
these people who's so introverted and so
out of society and have this
unbelievable gift,
which is also something really
remarkable to see and it's no wonder
those things are so popular,
they're psychologically stored nearly
interesting.
So okay,
so that's the actor first of the nokias
temptations,
and of course it's the first one because
he's entering the social world and the
temptation in the social world is to be
exactly what other people want you to be
and the thing that's cool about that is
that is what you should be doing right?
When you go out in your peers,
you should be not subjugating your
individuality to your peers because
that's not exactly right.
That's kind of based on an inhibition
model.
You know you've got aggression that
you've got bad habits.
They have to be inhibited.
You learn that by interacting with your
peers.
It's not the right model.
PSJ,
that's a Freudian model.
Piaget was was correct about that.
He basically pointed out that what
should happen is let's say with your
aggression and hopefully you have some,
is that it gets socialized and so you
learn how to play games,
but you don't drop your drive to when
you integrate that in the games and so
you try to,
when you try to play hard,
but if you're defeated or you hit
something negative,
you don't respond negatively and you can
keep that all bounded within being a
fair,
a good player,
a fair,
a fair player,
and that means what's happening is you
just learn how to play a game or a set
of games that also includes the darker
parts of you and they actually become
part of your force of character.
It's way better if you can pull that
off.
It's and,
and that's what you definitely want to
do as an adult.
Like all you people are going to have to
learn to negotiate on your own behalf
and that that's really hard.
It means that you have to know what you
want.
You have to be able to communicate it
and you have to be able to say no and to
say no.
You have to be built on a solid
foundation.
You have to have options,
so you've got to remember that as you go
through your life is like if you don't
have options,
you can't negotiate with someone and if
you're not willing to use them,
they win period,
because if you're asking your boss for
more money,
say the answer is no because he doesn't
have any spare money lying around that
he can just give to you and lots of
other people are asking,
so some of that zero some stuff,
you know,
not all of it because often you
cooperate with people in the whole pot
can grow,
but some of it's zero sum and so you
better have a case made.
It's like,
here's why I should.
Here's how much money I should have.
Here's why.
Here's the benefit to you that will
accrue if you don't,
if you do it,
here's the consequences that you don't.
They're actually real.
They will cost you and I will do them.
It's like then you can negotiate and you
don't do that rudely,
but those arguments,
you better have them in order like so.
For example,
if you're going to negotiate for a raise
or a or a status shift,
you better have your resume out,
hand all polished up and nowhere else
you're going to look for a job and you
better be able to get one because
otherwise you're just.
You're weak and you will not win the
negotiation,
and if you're too agreeable,
so your conflict avoidant,
you will make less money across time
that's already been well established and
that's because you don't have teeth,
not enough,
and so in the little micro contests that
you're going to have every day,
you're going to incrementally lose to
people who are more aggressive,
who have bigger teeth,
and that's what happens so,
so don't let that happen.
You want to,
you place yourself so you can negotiate
because otherwise
you're just a facade and when a real
battle of facade is just torn down right
away.
So yes,
well say no more.
Well,
the cricket,
he's supposed to be helping to pop it
out,
but he overslept.
It's like,
that's just another indication that he's
not everything he could be yet,
and that's really,
that took me a long time to puzzle out
with regards to interpreting this movie.
I could not figure out,
alright,
I told you this,
if the bug is the person who opens the
hero narrative and who can guide the
transformations of time and who has the
same initials as Jesus Christ,
it's like,
is like knighted by nature herself.
Why is he such an idiot?
It's a very difficult thing to figure
out,
but,
but the idea that the conscience isn't
omniscient,
even though it has that sort of,
that voice of,
of let's say common sense.
Uh,
and that fits very nicely in with the
Freudian idea of the Super Ego.
Again,
because the Super Ego can be flawed,
it can be too harsh,
it can not be,
it can not be properly developed.
You see that often with people who are
orderly,
so they're high in conscientiousness,
conscientiousness fragments into
industriousness and orderliness orderly.
People like willpower,
they're very judgmental and they like
things to be exactly where they're
supposed to be,
but they're also very self punitive.
So conservatives are much more likely to
be orderly by the way it's.
It's one of the best predictors of
conservative low openness is the best
predictor,
but right after that is high,
high orderliness.
So.
And it's associated with disgust
sensitivity,
which is really an amazing thing.
We'll talk about that later.
Anyways,
the cricket.
Oh,
he falls down on his first day on the
job.
He's not as conscientious a conscious.
He's not as conscientious a conscience
as he should be.
So he's feeling pretty stupid.
He's got his little millionaire clothes
on there,
but he's really not living up to them.
So he does catch up to the Fox and the
puppet however,
and tries to dissuade Pinocchio from
going down this road hand.
Of course the cat.
Well you can see what the cat is doing.
Mary's going to big hammer,
big Mellott and he's gonna.
He also shows you just exactly how much
of a clue he has.
He's going to wall up the bug who's
sitting on the foxes hat,
which I think he actually does and you
know,
then the farcs can't get out of his hat
and has to talk through his hat,
which basically is what he's doing the
whole time.
Anyways.
So this I really like.
So you see on the left here that cricket
is speaking inside this flower,
you know,
and like I said,
there's nothing accidental in these,
in these representations.
So these are artists who are coming up
with these compositions and they fantasy
has a structure and so the cricket is
speaking out of this flower that has.
Well,
you could think about it as,
it has a sexualized element.
So you can think about that as a part of
it and not part of the feminine part of
it.
Well,
they are flowers after all.
They are the sex organs of plants.
And so,
and that's very much the same over here
as this is the Yoni and lingam misses
from,
uh,
from Hindu cultures.
And so,
and they see there's a snake wrapped
around that.
And so that's masculine and feminine
with a snake wrapped around it and
that's,
that's a wholly representation,
you know,
sacred representation and it represents,
it represents the deepest reality.
That's one way of thinking about it,
like chaos and order surrounded by the
snake.
It's the same.
Exactly the same idea.
And so the cricket speaks out of that
already know that because the cricket is
the conscience and he's been awakened in
part by by Japan,
Eto and the good father and awakened in
part by the good fairy and nature.
And so he speaks with those voices and,
and he's also a manifestation of,
of the underlying chaos itself because
nature and culture spring out of chaos.
You know,
I already showed you that schematic
representation.
Okay.
So I'll just,
I'll just end this scene and then we'll
have like a 15 minute break.
Okay.
So anyways,
the cricket tries to make a case for why
Pinocchio shouldn't go off to be a
celebrity,
but you know,
it's a hard case to make because the Fox
is very manipulative and Pinocchio is
naive and it sounds like a good offer.
And also the Fox is actually quite
forceful,
you know,
he basically takes them by the hand.
So the temptation is,
and this is something else I liked about
the movie,
you can't just say,
well the puppet gets what he deserves
because he's little naive and what he's
facing is really malevolent,
truly malevolent and physically
overpowering.
And so the movie does a nice job of not
minimizing the threat that's posed by
this particular temptation.
And that's part of what makes it art.
Okay,
good.
So we'll stop there.
We'll have a break for 15 minutes and
then we'll start with the stage.
So.
Alright.
So here we are at the big event in
Pinocchio is off to be a celebrity.
And the cricket is watching.
And a Pinocchio basically.
Well he's got some natural talent
because he's,
he's a puppet,
he doesn't have strings and he goes on
stage and with strings and then he drops
his strings and the whole crowd was
amazed.
And the crowds should be amazed when
that happens.
Right.
You can imagine when a kid goes to
school and show some independence that
that's actually gonna.
People are gonna notice that he's his
peers are gonna notice that the teachers
are going to notice that maybe it's too
much independence even.
Right,
but it's still a.
It is a remarkable thing to like.
It's so interesting.
You know,
you can see marked signs of independence
and children.
Well,
right from the time they're born
basically because what's one of the
things that's really funny about infants
is that,
you know,
when they're crying you always say,
oh,
the baby's while you're crying.
It's maybe sad.
It's like,
no,
a lot of the time that maybe is angry
and the way that we know that is because
you could do facial expression coding on
infants just like on,
on adults and you can tell what emotion
they're expressing and very frequently,
like when the kid starts to recognize
his mom explicitly because he or she
knows the smell right away pretty much
in the sound of the voice.
But visually,
if someone comes in and it isn't who the
baby wants,
so generally it isn't mom,
the baby will start to cry,
but it's not [inaudible] the baby.
Sad.
Generally it's because it's angry that
mom didn't show up and that's an early
sign of will.
It's like this kid has this kid wants
things like and it's perfectly willing
to tell you about that and of course a
two year old who's having a temper
tantrum is in some sense doing the same
thing.
It's poorly integrated will and
independence obviously,
but it certainly runs contrary to what
you want.
You don't want your two year old having
a temper tantrum in the middle of the
toy store.
It's extraordinarily embarrassing for
you and while for you,
but it's also embarrassing for the two
year old.
That's one of the reasons I think that
that sort of thing should be carefully
socialized rapidly because it's actually
humiliating for the kid because other
people don't like that and they're very
judgemental about like they won't say
anything usually,
but sometimes they will,
but they're not happy about the fact
that that's happening and they will
judge the child negatively.
So you don't want your child to be
behaving in a way in public that makes
other people think badly of them.
It's really,
it's really not good and so you,
you're part of your job as a parent is
to not expose your child to that sort of
experience,
especially not repeatedly.
It's really hard on them or they get
narcissistic,
which is also really hard on them.
It's just,
it takes a lot longer to manifest
itself.
So anyways,
he's off on stage and Stromboli
introduces him and talks about how
wonderful this is going to be and Nokia,
it comes out on stage with the strings
on and drops them and then he falls down
the steps and put his nose in the whole.
It makes a fool out of himself and
that's when Stromboli first time
Stromboli shows his true character
because he just really yells and screams
at him and he has his back to the
audience Stromboli while he's doing
this.
So he's not noticing how the audience is
reacting.
Typical to radical parent,
right?
Who's not noticing that society is
reacting a different way than in him and
he's not happy about it.
And Pinocchio of course is dazed and
feels like a fool and he is a fool.
So that's appropriate.
But then Stromboli,
here's the crowd laughing,
and as soon as he turns around,
he's like all smiles again,
and so that's the first time you get
insight into what sort of puppet master
he is.
He's there to please the crowd and that
all and he's there to look good in
public.
But fundamentally he's a tyrant.
And so,
and I guess that's the problem,
the problem with false celebrity is that
the negative spirit of the crowd becomes
your master,
right?
Because to be a celebrity you have to be
a crowd pleaser.
And if you're pleasing the kind of crowd
who likes a celebrity like you,
which is,
and there's not much reason for that,
then it's not exactly like you're
appealing to the proper side of the
crowd and you've become,
it's puppet one way or another.
And maybe it's rewarding you with wealth
perhaps and with attention,
but fundamentally it's not.
It's not something I would recommend if
you want to stay reasonably
psychologically healthy for any
reasonable amount of time,
you're going to sell yourself out.
And I don't mean not in any casual way,
you know?
All right.
So anyways,
Stromboli changes from the tyrant to the
good father in half a second,
He gives Pinocchio Pat on the head
despite the fact that he's made a
mistake,
looks all kind and the show continues.
Now,
the cricket is not very happy about
this.
He's sitting in the stage watching.
He's very angry and let's say disgusted
by what's happening,
partly because Pinocchio was making a
fool of himself.
Now that's an interesting thing.
You know,
human beings blush.
In fact,
if I remember correctly,
the name Adam,
you know,
like Adam and eve is related to the
capacity to blush.
Now that,
that comes from something I read a long
time ago,
and that might be wrong,
but Adam does manifest shame in the
sight of God.
So there,
there is a relationship there,
but anyways,
um,
people do make fools of themselves for,
for public display.
And you can tell you've done that in
some sense,
not always if you blush because you've
either said something you shouldn't have
and you know,
you realize that,
which is more like you've,
you've tried to be funny and gotten a
little bit too far.
And sometimes that can be really funny,
or you said something that you know,
to be false,
manipulative,
deceitful beneath you or any of those
things,
and you'll have an automatic response to
it.
It'd be ashamed and blush.
And one theory about that is that you
can trust people who blush.
And so because you know that their
conscience will be trade that and so
that even if they are lying,
they tell you.
And so it's an interesting theory,
you know,
because blush is definitely like,
it's a facial display,
you know,
it's right out there where people can
see it.
So,
you know,
maybe that's true,
maybe it isn't,
but it's kind of an interesting idea.
Anyways.
The cricket is not happy with what's
going on.
He's not happy boats,
Stromboli and he's not happy about the
willingness of Pinocchio to make a fool
of himself to support this false
celebrity.
And so I actually think that's why the
celebrity types like that often get
narcissistic and arrogant.
You know,
it's because they,
they aren't paying attention,
they're not paying attention really to
what's happening inside of them.
They drowned it out because the glory.
And the money and all that is so
attractive and enticing.
They don't notice.
They refuse to notice what price they're
paying for it and they magnify up their
grandiosity and their arrogance to keep
that stuff all under control.
And then of course they get surrounded
by sycophants,
which is a really bad thing,
right?
They,
they get surrounded by people who will
tell them exactly what they want to hear
and that's really bad if what you want
to hear from other people is not good
for you to surround yourself with people
who won't offer you genuine criticism or
even genuine reward.
It's the same thing like you want for
me,
that I differentially reward and punish
you in approximately the way that the
good part of the crowd will.
That's what you want from all your
friends because then your interactions
with them can generalize out to the
broader community in a productive way.
And so a good friend,
you know,
I mean your friends tend to be on the
supportive side and perhaps that's
appropriate.
Assuming there's reciprocity,
but a good friend will also tell you
when one way or another,
when your behavior is starting to tilt
in a direction that's going to make you
unpopular with them and likely unpopular
with other people,
and of course that's what a parent is
supposed.
That's the prime job of a parent in my
estimation.
It's like,
don't do that.
Other people will hurt you if you do
that by exclusion,
by threat,
by failure to offer you an opportunity,
bad things will happen to you so you
can't do that,
and then you're a representative of the
social situation,
which is exactly what you should be,
not a friend,
so or at least not precisely a friend
that doesn't make you an enemy.
It makes you better than a friend.
Well,
so minimal cues on stage,
making a fool of himself and then he
gets all tangled up in other puppet
strings.
That's what happens to them and the and
then it all ends rather badly with
everything being a tangled mess on
stage,
but it also turns out to be rather
funny.
It's funny because he's surrounded by
angry Russians know,
which you know,
you could kind of view that as a
potential lesson is that if you're a
puppet on a stage and you mess around
too much,
you just might get tangled up with a
bunch of angry Russians and these are
costs acts.
That's exactly what happened.
So anyways,
of course,
no,
that's not what's happening here,
but it's still funny.
So
Stromboli is not happy with the tangled
mass,
but then the crowd reacts very
positively and then that confuses the
conscience because he thinks,
well look,
this is horrible.
This guy's a tyrant,
like Pinocchio's making a fool of
himself.
Everything turns into a tangled mess,
but the crowd goes crazy and well being
a fool.
That can be entertaining,
right?
So it's hard to tell when the crowd,
especially at a spectacle,
because that's this crowd is at a
spectacle.
You just don't know exactly why it is
that they're responding positively,
but you've definitely give them what you
want.
And you can see this look on strombolis
face.
It's like this false.
Again,
this false kindness and generosity,
public facing and oh well anyways,
the conscience is very confused and I
really think this is an important thing
because I've often thought I spent a lot
of time thinking about Hitler and I was
thinking,
well,
how do you get into a state like that?
You know,
can you think?
Well,
he was a dictator and he led his people
down a bad path.
It's like,
that's not right.
That is not what happened.
They had a conspiracy together and went
down a bad path.
Now think about it this way.
Hmm.
If one person thinks something about
you,
it's like whatever.
Right?
But if five people tell you that,
well,
what?
Then then to start to start not taken
that seriously.
It's kind of narcissistic.
Right?
And if it isn't five,
let's say it's 15 people tell you the
same thing or act the same way towards
you.
It's like probably you should clue in,
well what if you're a politician and
you're trying out a bunch of different
ideas and you're good at interacting
with the crowd,
you're charismatic,
you watch the crowd,
but you're not necessarily all that
articulate.
You don't have your values all
straightened out,
but you're kind of angry too and maybe
that's because you spent a bunch of time
in World War One,
world war one in the trenches which was
like no joke and all your friends got
blown up.
You had when you were unemployed and
then you tried to be an artist and that
didn't work out even though you were
moderately talented and then maybe the
economy fell apart completely on you
hyperinflation and then maybe there was
a communist menace coming in from the
east and they're genuinely was and so
you're not the world's happiest clam at
that point and you're talking to people
who aren't that happy either because
they were also badly defeated in world
war one.
And then they had a terrible treaty.
They had decided they lost part of their
territory and so the crowd's not happy
and neither are you.
And there's reason for it,
and so you start talking to them,
you don't know what you're upset about
and neither does the crowd,
so you start to articulate some things
about why you might be upset and some of
them fall flat,
but you're paying attention to the
crowd.
So you stop saying those things and some
of the things make the crowd really wake
up and listen.
And so you start seeing more of those
things.
Right?
It's an.
It's an unconscious dialectic between
you and the crowd.
It's mediated by consciousness,
but it's not like you're sitting there
saying,
although you might be,
I'm going to tell this crowd more what
it wants to hear.
It's more sophisticated than that.
And so you do that thousand times and
you do that to ever increasing crowds
and the crowd really starts to go mad
and they basically tell you that you're
the savior of the nation.
It's like at what?
How many bloody people have to tell you
that before you start to believe it,
you know?
I would say with a typical person,
100,
we'll do it now.
That'll get you going,
man.
If a hundred people tell you
specifically why you're special,
you're going to be thinking,
even if you're kind of humbled to begin
with,
you're going to be thinking,
gees,
there's got to be something to this man,
but if it's a million people and they're
roaring their approval,
well,
and then when it's a whole nation,
it's like good luck with standing that
there's just not a chance.
How are you going to withstand that?
Now you could be like Gandhi and you
could have taken that into account
beforehand because he did he read
tolstoy by the way,
he was a student of tolstoy and that's,
it's very interesting because tolstoy
was the person who developed the
techniques of nonviolence that Gandhi
used.
And tolstoy was also a deeply religious
writer apart from his novels,
which are not,
I wouldn't say really in the religious
category,
although they're profound,
um,
tolstoy stressed humility with
nonviolence.
He really stressed that.
And that's what Gandhi took to heart.
So he lived a very,
very,
very simple bare bones,
ascetic life.
And that was to kind of see if he could
keep his damn ego tamp down.
Well,
the groundswell was building behind him,
you know,
and he dressed really simply and he
didn't own much and he ate very simply
and he just tried to stay away from the
whole materialistic success element that
would be an element of what would turn
them into an actor and also inflate his
ego and you know,
he seemed to do that pretty well.
You know,
he certainly.
Well,
he led a nonviolent revolution that
resulted in the,
in the independence of India.
It also produced a terrible civil war
and the separate separation of the
Muslim Indians from the Hindu Indians
and.
But I think you can precisely
laid out at the feet of Gandhi.
Right?
But,
but what I'm saying is that you have to
be an extraordinary person.
You have to be extraordinarily wise and
you have to take ridiculous precautions
if you're going to put yourself in the
public sphere like that and expose
yourself to that kind of adulation
without becoming a puppet of the crowd.
And that's what happened to Hitler.
I mean,
it's not like he wasn't also a conscious
manipulator and surrounded himself by
people who were propagandists.
And all of that,
so there was a conscious element,
but you've got to think these things
through and see how that dialectic
develops.
Like he learned how to appeal to the
darkest fantasies of the crowd.
He was really,
really good at it and that was a
dialectic process,
right?
The crowd told them what they wanted to
hear and it's the crowds a mob at that
point.
So I don't have to take responsibility
for the fact that I'm screaming my
approval when I'm surrounded by a
million people so I can scream my
approval for whatever I want forever.
Whatever dark revengeful fantasy might
be playing out in my imagination because
I'm not going to be held accountable for
it
anyways.
The crickets confused and it's no wonder
it's like the public has rendered its
judgment and the judgment is positive.
So when I wrote the book on which this
course is based,
I was thinking,
how am I going to judge success?
And then I thought,
well,
there's sort of four,
there's a two by two matrix of success.
You could say it's a great book.
No one reads it.
That happens.
So what do you,
what do you do about that?
It's like Nietzsche and sold virtually
nothing in his lifetime.
Right?
And you know,
that's happened to lots of artists.
So then it's a terrible book and
everyone loves it.
That happens too.
And then it's a great book and everyone
loves it and then it's a terrible book
and everyone hates it.
That's probably a better category
actually,
that like it's a terrible book that,
and everyone loves it.
I mean,
you wouldn't pick a terrible book that
everyone hates if you had a choice,
but at least the quality and the
response match,
at least it's truthful light,
great book,
good response.
But the problem with those four
categories is you can't really tell
which category your production falls
into,
right?
Because how do you know?
And you know,
I think you should assume horrible book,
bad response because that's the most
likely of all four of those categories.
That's the one that's most likely to be
true,
but just purely on,
on actuarial ground foot say so.
Alright.
So anyways,
the cricket wanders away because he
obviously,
not only was he late for work that day,
but he turned out to be wrong about
everything.
So we,
let's Pinocchio go off and his adventure
and Stromboli puts them in this little
kind of like a,
uh,
traveling,
touring wagon,
you know,
and away they go.
And the cricket thinks,
well,
he is an of the conscience isn't needed
anymore on this journey towards unearned
celebrity.
Well,
meanwhile,
back at the,
as they say,
um,
the puppet is supposed to come home
after school,
but he doesn't,
he doesn't show up.
And the kitten and the fish and Japan,
we were all waiting there for him,
ready to eat.
Excuse me.
But he doesn't show up.
And so Japan goes out into the rain to
look for him and he can't find them.
And then we're,
we see the inside of the traveling show
cart and Stromboli is having a snack and
counting all the money that he's made
from tonight's performance and
hypothetically dividing it up with a
puppet.
So we've got this little stack of gold
and uh,
some of it's false.
So somebody paid with a looks like a
little Washer,
like a mechanical Washer,
and it's bent,
and so he curses about that for awhile
even though it's interesting because
he's made all this money,
it's been really successful.
But this one little error is enough to
enrage him,
which is very ungrateful and tyrannical.
It's like,
look,
you've got 100 gold pieces.
Someone slipped you a fake one.
It's like you could have had 101.
It's still a pretty good day.
All things considered,
you know,
you've got to make a bit of allowance
for error,
which is something a tyrant does not do.
So and that's perfect because if you
don't make allowance for error at all,
then people are always guilty of
something and if you're a tyrant that's
exactly what you want and people are
always guilty of something.
So the tyrant who's willing to exploit
that is always on solid ground.
So
anyways,
he doesn't share with Pinocchio and he
puts them in a birdcage jail.
And then he also shows them this other
puppet that has an ax through him that
was the previous puppet who didn't
precisely perform as he was supposed to.
And so there's a big threat there.
It's like you stay in that jail,
you do exactly what I want,
or it's off to the woodpile for you to
be burned.
And so well that that's just we're
thinking about because that's kind of
what happens with tyrants and so and,
and literally not just metaphorically
so.
So the cricket is basically wondering
what in the world he should do.
And then the cart rolls by and he gets
an inkling or is.
And I don't quite remember this,
that Pinocchio is in there and might be
in trouble or he thinks that up.
I'm sorry,
I can't remember that.
But he ends up anyways.
He ends up inside the car and he,
he finds the traveling part and he goes
inside and then he tries to pick the
lock because he's a bug you can climb
inside.
He tries to pick the lock.
He tries to get Pinocchio out of the
jail that he's been.
And he sort of collaborated himself
into,
you know,
and it's,
it's interesting because if you read,
for example,
if you read Solzhenitsyn's Gulag
archipelago,
which I would highly recommend,
one of the things you find is that if
you were arrested by the,
by the KGB,
by the secret police and in the Soviet
Union,
and you were
hauled off to,
uh,
to uh,
to,
uh,
like a tribunal,
a Jew before a judge.
They wanted you to admit that you were
guilty.
You had to,
like,
they torture you until you confessed,
or you could just confess and that are
always found that so mysterious.
It's like the kick down your door,
they know perfectly well that they
haven't got any more on you than they've
got on anyone else.
And yet you have to go through the damn
trial and you have to admit that they're
right.
It's like,
why?
Why do they even bother with that?
Why don't they just throw your sorry ass
into the camp,
which is essentially what's going to
happen anyways.
Why do they need your collaboration?
No,
I've never quite figured that out.
I think it's partly because they're not
willing to let you stand in opposition
to the rules because the mere fact that
you will do that means that you exist as
something that is allowed to exist
outside the rules and they're not having
any of that,
so that's part of it,
but there's more to it.
There's more to it than that.
It's like the drama of collaboration.
So one of the things I learned about
societies like the Soviet Union,
and this is true of all tyrannical
societies,
is that the idea that that's top down
and that people are just following
orders.
They're good people,
but they're just following orders.
It's like you can forget about that.
That's a stupid theory.
When a society becomes tyrannical like
that,
the tyranny exists at every single level
of the society.
You tyrannized your own conscience.
So let's say you're a true believer.
You're a true believer in Marxist
Utopia,
let's say,
or national socialist third,
right?
That's going to last a thousand years
and be racially pure.
You really believed that and that's
supposed to be a perfect state and
that's already been delivered to you.
And so what that means is that in so far
as you're a true believer,
your own suffering becomes heretical
because to the degree that you're
suffering and you're living proof of the
fact that the system is not delivering
what it promised to deliver,
and so you have to suppress that.
You have to become your own tyrant.
You can't admit that anything's gone
wrong,
and of course you can't talk about a
tier family because one out of three of
them are government informers,
just like one out of three of everyone.
And you're certainly not going to
mention it in the workplace because
unless you're a devout communist party
member,
you're not going anywhere.
And if any of your ancestors were like
land owners or or bourgeoisie,
it's like you're done.
You're done class guilt,
man.
You're not going anywhere.
And then every single level of the
bureaucracy is exactly the same as that.
And on the top there is a tyrant,
but the tyrant is everywhere,
everywhere from the peak to the soul.
It's all tyranny.
And everyone participates in that by
lying about everything.
And that's why you see what happens
next.
In the,
in the movie,
So Pinocchio was in jail and he,
he's there because he was naive and he
allowed himself to be enticed to because
he did something that would've run
contrary to his conscience,
but the movie doesn't put up Straw man,
you know,
the poor damn puppet got tangled into
this is conscience wasn't even around.
So you have to have some sympathy for
them but doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter because he ends up in
jail and he can't get out.
And the fact that it in some ways wasn't
his fault,
doesn't change the fact that he's in
jail and he can't get out.
And then his is.
I was watching Louis c k the other night
and he was talking about children lying.
He was talking about his nine year old
daughter lying.
And he said,
well,
it's no,
it's no wonder your children lie and
it's no wonder it's impossible for you
to stop them because you know,
you're talking to someone who's his head
would scrape the roof.
They weigh like three times as much as
you and they're capable of force and
they're intimidating and they say to you
something like,
could you,
could you take that last cookie after I
told you not to?
And you're thinking,
oh no,
I took a cookie.
What am I going to do?
And then you,
you,
you get a genius idea in your head which
children,
smarter children learn to lie earlier.
Children with high Iq is learned to lie
younger and and Ck says,
well,
it's like you've just been handed a
magic.
Get out of jail free card.
You can just say,
no,
I didn't take that cookie and worse than
that,
it works in every single situation.
If you get away with it and now you're
supposed to learn not to do that.
I said,
well great.
So that's the thing about Comedians,
you know,
they'll tell you the underlying truth,
which is why people think they're so
funny,
like the gesture and it King's court,
right?
He's the only one who's allowed to tell
the king the truth because he's beneath
contempt.
That's what comedians do.
And so.
Well,
so what happens is,
well,
Pinocchio Pinocchio's not very happy
about this,
right?
It's really breaking them up and the
blue fairy appears again from the star.
Same Way.
So what this means is,
is I think this is right,
this is something you've talked about it
and it was also extraordinarily
brilliant.
He said that it's one thing to break a
rule when you don't really know the rule
you can,
for whatever reason,
you seem to get a bit of a free pass for
that,
but if then you know the rule and then
you break it anyways,
you get hit a lot harder.
And I know that's true and I even think
I figured out why it was true at one
point,
but I can't remember the moment,
but there's something,
there's something about,
it's like the severity of a moral error
isn't quite as massive if you're
genuinely ignorant and unconscious about
the rule and maybe it's because you're
not violating your own belief system as
much when you engage in the activity.
It's something like that.
So.
So anyways,
Pinocchio is in there and he,
he's partly at fault at least because
he's naive and,
and he's very desperate about it,
but it's also because his conscience
isn't functioning very well,
so he has his reasons and so whatever
the blue fairy shows up again,
mother nature steps in to aid him.
And so,
and that is true I would say because
it's not like you get walloped or killed
every time you make a mistake,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's kind of interesting.
And especially that's the case with kids
is like we have more leeway from,
for them,
whether nature does,
that's a different issue.
But I would say yes because you know,
kids are really cute and they're
appealing and so,
and they're,
they're naive and they're kind of
helpless.
They have those motions even that
indicate helplessness and that's
associated with the natural apprehension
of cuteness.
Right?
So cuteness is big eyes,
small knows symmetrical features,
baby like features.
I'm helpless movements.
Um,
that elicits sympathy and compassion and
it doesn't cross species.
And so does the cry.
And my roommate when I was in college,
had a niece who is quite young,
boat year and half old,
I think,
and we had a cat wildcat and uh,
and it was really fighty cat,
partly because of me because I would
always play with it and it would let him
fight with me quite a lot.
So was a fighty cat.
And,
and,
uh,
that little girl would come over and,
you know,
maybe she'd cry that cat was like,
they are right now trying to figure out
what was wrong and the like,
the cat would use its claws on me,
but it would never use its claws on the
little kid,
you know.
And I thought,
well that's,
that's indication of that cross species
cuteness,
you know,
and,
and you're all attracted to that more or
less.
And the more maternal you are,
the more you're attracted to such
things.
But you know,
you see something on Youtube and you go,
ah.
And that's like,
that's so cute.
It's like,
yeah,
it is,
it,
it appeals to exactly this.
It,
it.
If it appeals to this,
couldn't commentation of infantile
features.
And,
and,
uh,
it brings out compassion unless you're
psychopathic,
so it's a good thing,
but you know,
it can be manipulated,
that's for sure.
Women actually manipulate it with
makeup,
which is quite,
quite sneaky and go to them.
So anyways,
so the blue fairy shows up,
so that's nature.
So what I'm saying is that nature will
cut kids a break if you think of nature
in the guise of,
well their mother for example,
but even the biology of other,
because we're wired to accept behavior
from children that we wouldn't accept
from other people.
So nature will forgive.
So she shows up in your heavenly guys
and says what's going on?
And Pinocchio again,
because he's not youth,
but also because he's not good.
He's not evil either.
He's,
he's neither or both.
It depends on how you look at it.
And he also has no idea how smart he is
and how smart he isn't or how smart the
person he's talking to his.
And uh,
instead of admitting what he's done,
he lies about it.
And that's interesting because it does
suggest that he understands at some
level that he set himself up for this
because you know,
he could just say,
he could have just told the truth,
this horrible Fox kidnap me and sold me
to this slave holder,
which is true.
It's a lot more true than the story he
tells.
He tells a story about some monster,
you know,
a fictional monster.
He coulda told even three quarters of
the truth and how it work.
But he doesn't.
He just obscures the story entirely.
And this is the part of the movie that
people remember.
And I'd edited this out for years when I
was talking about this movie.
I forgot why it was so significant
because nose grows right and it grows
too ridiculous length.
And why is that?
I think it was Mark Twain,
Samuel Clemens,
I think who said,
one of the advantages to telling the
truth is that you don't have to remember
what you said and that God that's worth
listening to because.
So there's a bunch of things I've
learned as a clinician and one of them
is because you're often in really weird
situations with people if you're a
clinician because things happen that
don't happen normally and you don't know
what to do.
And so what I've learned is I just say
what I just say,
what's happening,
whatever it is,
regardless of what it is,
you know,
I'll just try to describe it as
accurately as I can and not worry about
in some sense,
not worried about the consequences,
you know,
like I'm not going out of my way to
cause trouble.
But if you're in a really,
and I'm telling you this can save your
life at times,
especially if you're dealing with
someone who's paranoid,
who's really paranoid,
you do not lie to someone who's paranoid
and violet.
Because as soon as you lie,
you're aligned with the forces that are
persecuting them and they're going to be
because paranoid it makes people
hypervigilant,
like they're on amphetamines.
In fact,
you can make people paranoid by giving
them enough amphetamines and you can
make paranoid people more paranoid by
giving them amphetamines.
So they're hypervigilant.
Because they feel that everything is
predatory and against them,
and so they're watching you like you
would not believe way more than you're
watching them.
And if you flicker ally while you're
talking to them and they're really on
the edge,
you,
you're done.
So it's what?
It's one thing to really know if you're
ever in a really bad situation and you
don't know what to do,
you tell the truth.
Minimally you don't disclose too much.
That's just another lie.
You tell the truth minimally and
carefully and hopefully,
and you might get out of it,
you might get out of it,
but if you falsify it,
look the hell out.
So the truth is a real.
It's a real mechanism of protection in
dangerous situations.
You know?
So if someone's trying to intimidate you
and you,
you think they might get violent,
that they ask you if you're afraid,
then you tell them that you're terrified
and that you hope that things will go
okay.
Or you say,
I'll give you an example.
One time I was in an airport and uh,
we're in this lineup to fly back to
Canada that said international flights.
And so as long line up like 50 people
and we got it,
I got about three from the front,
it was still like 40 people behind me
and the guy behind the counter decided
that he was just going to shut down the
line and that we could all go to this
other line,
which was like 300 people long and I
suggested that he not do that because
we'd been standing there for half an
hour and that he could just deal with
the 20 of us that were less than and
like have a clue.
So he called the sheriff right away and
this was down in Florida and it wasn't
that long after nine slash 11.
And so these guys came up and they were
armed and they came and said,
looked at me because of course he told
them that I was causing trouble,
which I wasn't.
I was just trying to not
left.
What would you say?
An arrogant bureaucratic scum rat take
advantage of me.
So which is not the same as causing
trouble.
So anyways,
as soon as the cops came up,
I said,
look,
I'm going to do exactly what you tell me
to do right now and I'm not going to
cause any trouble,
but I would like you to hear what
actually happened.
And so that,
that's a good example of a situation
like that.
It's like if someone's got,
you know,
Bravo Bravado,
it's a very bad idea and I was going to
do exactly what they told me because you
know,
they didn't know who I was and I didn't
know what they had been told.
So anyhow,
the problem with lying is that it's a
hydro and kids find this out very early
because you tell one lie and what
happens is it has one of the
consequences that you expect.
Maybe you'd get away with it,
but it has three or four others that you
don't expect.
And so it's like it grows some,
some complexity and then you have to
tack a lie on each of those little
complexity outcrops.
And then they grow three more
complexities and soon this little light
turns into great big ball of lies.
And at some point it becomes painfully
evident to everyone,
and by that time you're in such,
you see this with politicians like that
guy who was sexting.
Um,
Anthony Wiener.
Yeah.
Perfect name for him,
man.
It's so funny.
Uh,
I shouldn't make that comment because
it's so obvious,
but it's still funny,
but you know,
he,
that's exactly what happened to him.
It's like,
it wasn't even so much the event because
people are stupid.
They make mistakes.
And actually the public is somewhat
forgiving if you say,
yeah,
Jesus,
I'm a real moron and you know,
like really seriously,
how could I do that?
But I did.
And like I'll try not to do it again.
But what happens with politicians is,
and I'm not speaking specifically of
politicians,
is they'll make an error and it gets
exposed and then they make three others
trying to cover it up.
Happened with Nixon for example.
And then the whole thing just turns into
a complete scandal.
And maybe they could have got out of it
at the beginning by just telling the
truth.
It's like,
yes,
I'm an idiot.
You know,
I'll try not to do it again.
Well that isn't what happens in this
case in Pinocchio grows this elaborate
series of lies and the ferry is willing
to be a little generous to him because
he's little and cute and he's still a
puppet and she tells him
not to do that and that she's going to
give them a pass this time,
but that she isn't going to be able to
intervene on his behalf again.
And that's partly one of the things
that's quite interesting about people
who have roots,
Soliah and ideas about children.
So children are all good and they get
corrupted by society,
which is half true because they're also
not good and they get shaped and,
and discipline by society.
But there were so many types.
Softer are very interesting when their
kids hit teenage years or when they're
judging,
like say criminal teenagers.
It's like the child is perfect until
they hit like 11.
Then they turned into a teenager and
then they're like thugs.
So they go from good to thug in one
move.
You know?
And,
and you often see that in families too
that have treated especially their
daughters like a princess,
you know,
and then they hit puberty and the
parents who have princess them to death
have no idea what to do with them.
And so then they become demonized and so
the,
the overly good that child turns into
the overly wicked teenager and sometimes
they lack that out to one of the things
I've seen with girls who are
held in princess esteem when they're
little and their parents have too tight
of a grip on them and too much of a
demand for good behaviors,
they'll find some nasty character to
associate with who will tear them out of
the family.
You know,
bikers are really good for that sort of
thing.
So you.
And especially if you have some vengeful
thoughts towards your parents,
nice biker is your perfect solution to
that problem.
Okay.
We'll go through this scene and then I
think we'll call it a day.
Okay.
So now Pinocchio was gone free.
He's been united with his conscience.
He's learned a couple of lessons.
Don't be an actor and don't lie.
And those things are quite similar,
right?
And especially once you're caught in
your actor trap,
don't lie to get out because that will
just make it worse.
So that's the first of his trials,
his moral trials on the road to becoming
real.
All right now,
now here we are at a different place.
We're at this,
I think it's called the red lobster in.
It's a shadowy place,
right?
It's kind of cave like,
so it's like the,
it's an underground entrance to
somewhere that's not good.
And so,
and it's a foggy night and you can't
really see.
So everything's murky and,
and gloomy.
They're.
And so inside we see the coachman and
the Fox and uh,
had an acat and the coachman.
The coachman is a bad guy.
He's that mask that we saw.
First of all,
he's the archetype of that mask that was
judgmental about Pinocchio having a
voice.
And it's like one of the things you said
about the shadow,
and this is I would say,
one of the primary impediments to
enlightenment is that if you start
looking at your motives for,
for misbehaving,
and,
and I mean by that,
something very specific.
I mean,
I don't mean that you're misbehaving by
someone else's standards.
I don't mean that.
I mean when you know by your own
standards that you're doing something
that's devious or malevolent or
underhanded,
you know it and you still do it.
So it's your own judgment you're
bringing to bear on yourself.
If you look at why you're doing that,
the longer you look at it,
the deeper hole you dig.
And so this is the Motif of Dante's
inferno fundamentally.
So Dante is inferno is a story about,
um,
I can't remember his name,
unfortunately,
might be Dante,
in fact,
although I don't remember.
He's led into hell by Virgil,
who's an,
who's an ancient,
who was an ancient philosopher,
thinker and hell has levels.
And so the outer level is,
this is a Christianized version of hell.
Um,
because there's hells of all sorts,
but this is a christianized version
version and so the on the outermost
levels of hell,
which is sort of like normal life are
the ancient philosophers and they're
still in hell because they weren't
Christian,
but it's kind of like,
it's like cheap motel hell instead of
the full pip thing,
you know?
And so then Dante goes deeper and deeper
into hell until it gets right to the
bottom of it.
And it's been a while since I read it,
but if I remember correctly,
Satan himself is encased in ice at the
bottom of hell,
surrounded by people who betray others.
And so Dante,
his notion was that the worst of all
possible violations of moral behavior
was betrayal and that they're in the
deepest levels of hell.
And I,
I really liked that idea.
I think it's true because if you trust
me,
then you're manifesting the necessary
courage that put someone through life.
You know,
if you're smart,
you don't trust me cause you're naive.
You Trust me knowing that I've full of
snakes and so are you.
But maybe we could cooperate and move
things along nicely,
we know and we could reduce each other
to the word to our word and we could
cooperate,
but you're awake,
you know,
and then I'd be trey that then I'm
undermining your necessary faith in,
in life and humanity and you can really
hurt someone that way.
Like the sometimes it's self betrayal,
but you can really do someone in that.
We can really traumatize them.
They can so that they can't recover and
so it's a really terrible thing to do to
someone and maybe it's the worst thing
and that was don idea and it's tied in.
That makes very interesting reading.
If you read it at the same time as
Milton's paradise lost because those are
metaphysical explorations.
This is what they are.
They're metaphysical explorations of the
terrible places you can end up and that
people do end up and also a metaphysical
explanation of what spirit takes you
there.
So because you might ask,
well why do you be traced someone?
And that is a deep question and so
you'll have your specific reasons.
But under that there'll be some other
reasons.
And under that,
there'll be some other reasons and under
that there'll be some other reasons and
if you go all the way to the bottom,
you come up with the ultimate reasons
why you'd be trade someone.
And when you look at that,
that will not be pretty.
That's when your proclivity for evil,
let's say you nights with the general
human proclivity for evil and you
discover just exactly what you're
capable of.
And so young's notion was that,
well that was a full encounter with the
shadow,
which is I suppose partly what this
course is about because one of the
things that I believe I told you at the
beginning was that I was going to try to
help you understand how it might be that
you could be in Auschwitz guard and to
really understand that that's a
horrifying thing to understand.
But I'll tell you,
if you want to grow some teeth,
that's a really good thing to
understand.
So we were talking about your capacity
to negotiate before.
Like if you aren't a monster,
you cannot negotiate.
But if you,
if you've got that under control,
then you don't have to be a monster.
It's really paradoxical.
So if you're just naive,
well you end up in jail and marionette
master has control over you.
That's not helpful.
So that's not good.
That just means you're useless and you
can be manipulated,
won't go out of your way to be
malevolent.
But it's mostly because you just don't
have the skills,
the organizational skills or,
or even the depth to do that.
You know you're good because you're
harmless.
That's not good.
That's easily manipulated.
And so you think,
well how do you get out of that?
Well,
partly you watch people because you know
what their light because you know what
you're like and that,
but you also know what you could do and
would do if you were pushed.
And so you don't have to show much of
that when you're negotiating with
someone for them to take you really
seriously.
So it's a strange thing,
you know.
But one of the things you pointed out
too was that what you most need to know
will be found where you least want to
look.
And that's because you haven't already
looked there and so it's a little
different for everyone,
right?
Because you're a particular place you'd
want to look isn't going to be the same
as your replace,
but you're going to have a place you
don't want to look and what you haven't
discovered.
That's where it is.
And so that's partly going to be
discovered by you looking at what you're
capable of,
what you're truly capable of.
And you know,
people especially on the Compassionate
and say,
well no,
I could never be like brutal like that
and that could be true,
but you can kill people with compassion.
No problem.
It happens.
That's the Freudian eatable situation.
So think about working in a nursing
home.
So there's actually a rule it's thumb,
which I also use to guide my
interactions with children and also with
my clients.
And I would say with people in general
do not do anything for anyone that they
can do themselves.
All you do is steal.
You just steal it from them.
So imagine you're working with really
elderly people.
You know they have Alzheimer's.
It's like really easy to do things for
them because while it isn't,
because it's really a hard job,
but it might be easier to do something
for them then to let them struggle
through it,
but you just speed their device.
Right.
By taking away the last vestiges of
their independence and you do the same
thing with kids.
It's like struggle through it.
Man.
Did you ever see my left foot?
That's a great movie.
It's about this author whose name
escapes me at the moment.
Brilliant.
It's brilliant movie and the person who
who played the part is Daniel Day Lewis.
I think he went to academy award for it,
but it's about this author in Ireland
who was.
I think he had cerebral palsy and all he
could really do was use his left foot.
That was it.
The rest of him was pretty spastic and
not in not controllable,
but he was there.
He was very intelligent.
He was with it and his dad would not
help him.
He had to drag himself up the damn
stairs with his left foot.
He just would not help him.
And what happened was he learned how to
live,
you know,
he actually,
he could function and the movie does the
book,
which is called my left foot and the
movie does a lovely job of laying that
out,
but you have to be one hardhearted son
of a bitch to let your son crawl up the
stairs with his left foot over and over.
You think about that.
But what's the alternative,
you know,
if he would have been.
And of course he lays this out in the
book,
if he would have been catered to,
he would have ended up just like you'd
expect someone who is always catered to.
So it's a very nice lesson in the
triumph of fostering independence over
the,
over to casual compassion.
That's what I would say.
Oh,
so you look at the coachman here kind of
looks like a demented Santa Claus.
You know,
it doesn't have a beard,
but he's,
it's a nice touch on the animators
parties.
Even got the pipe and the red suit.
And so he's listening to the Fox and the
cat brag about how much money they made
selling Pinocchio to the puppet master.
And how evil and terrible they are,
and they're bragging way and he's the
real thing.
Hey,
he's,
he's the real thing.
And he can see through their little
petty,
narcissistic,
grandiose tales of criminality and has
nothing but contempt for it.
And you can see that in his facial
expression.
It's like you sitting back a bit
thinking,
keep talking.
Bucko pretty soon I'm going to have,
you're right where I want you.
And so the Fox and the cat are drinking
beer and smoking cigarettes and talking
about how evil they are and,
and bragging about how they got one over
on the water,
like a four year old real impressive
guys.
Real impressive.
And uh,
the,
the coachman is thinking up his own
nefarious schemes right now for what he
might do with that puppet if he got his
hands on him.
And so that's what he reveals himself,
right?
So what you see filmmakers just do it
for a second.
And that's an archetype.
Old trip.
It's like you've got the Fox in the cat,
they're sort of petty examples of,
of criminality and evil.
And then you've got the coachman and
he's the real thing,
but he's not really shown anybody who he
is.
And then at one scene in the bar he lets
his guard down and he lets them see what
he's really like.
And so you see this all teeth and
predatory eyes and glee all at the same
time.
Right?
That's a bad combination.
I'm going to eat you and it's going to
make me very happy.
That's insanity.
You do not want to see that look on
someone's face.
And so that's the look.
And the Fox is traumatized by that.
He just like,
he thinks he's a bad guy and he's not.
He's just,
he just can't be a good guy.
He hasn't got the talent to be a bad
guy.
So.
And then he's talking to the coach when
I'm bragging and the coach was,
had enough of it and shows his real face
and it's like,
that's not good.
The Fox gets a real glimpse into hell
and that just terrifies.
Like he's and,
and then a coach when the other thing
the coachman does is reveal his plans
and his plans are to kidnap Pinocchio
along with a bunch of other boys,
had to take them to this place called
pleasure island and the Fox knows what's
going on there.
And so it's,
it's the foreshadowing of the next stage
of the adventure.
And so after the Fox and the cat or
terrified the coachman who takes you
along with him,
he has a little chat with them and they
described exactly what they're going to
do next and the Fox and the cat know
perfectly well that they're over their
head.
But at this point in their misadventures
there's no pulling back and I think
we'll stop there even though it's a
little early because that was a lot of
material and this is a really good place
to stop.
And so I'd be happy to take some
questions if you guys have some
questions.
We could take questions for like 10
minutes and then we'll call it a day.
So.
And you can me a question about anything
you want.
It's the beginning of the lecture,
but how do,
how does morality from
stronger and weaker to what's good and
what is it?
Well,
I think it depends to some degree on
what you mean by stronger.
So physical strength is one element and
like if you look at mythological heroes,
imagine that the stories of heroes are
fragmented elements of,
uh,
of the archetype and so one kind of
archetypal hero obviously as someone
who's physically strong,
you know,
you see that there's a great movie that
you could watch about this.
It's called Hitman Hart.
It's one of the best documentaries I've
ever seen and it's about this guy named
Bret Harte.
Bret Harte was for a while the most
famous Canadian on the planet and he was
a worldwide wrestling foundation,
I think.
What do they call it?
Wwf?
Yeah,
he was there like lead good guy.
And so he and wrestling,
I love the documentary because when I
was a little kid,
like four or five,
I used to watch his father whose name
was Stu Hart,
who ran this channel,
this wrestling confederation in Alberta.
And Stu Hart had,
I think eight boys and he trained all of
them to be pro wrestlers and part of the
movie is extraordinarily funny because
Stu Hart is in it and he's really old.
He's like 85 and he's just barely.
Can you imagine?
He was like a pro wrestler for 40 years,
like every joint is broken and he still
big but he's just barely moving and this
is this kid and another kid come over
and stu is telling the story about how
it used to take his boys into the
basement and toughen them up.
And I think Brent called that the
journey to pain or something like that.
His father would take all these kids
down there and wrestle with them and
push them right to the edge of their
pain tolerance constantly.
And so anyways,
they grew up tough.
There's no doubt about that.
And uh,
all his daughters married pro wrestlers
to,
and I think he had seven daughters.
So he's quite the character anyways.
These two kids,
they're like their late adolescence,
early adulthood come over and one of
them is pretty damn cocky and he's
listening to Stewart.
He says something smart like,
well,
you know,
you were pretty,
you were pretty tough with the old days.
Hey,
and stew looks at them and says,
well,
why?
Why don't you come down to the basement
with me?
And he says,
well look,
I don't want to hurt you old man.
And so,
so the filmmakers follow them into the
basement day and,
and like they're kind of standing there
and the old guy grabs him in a headlock,
takes him like,
he's like a snake,
a,
he's got her in a headlock like so fast
and then the kid doesn't know what to
do.
And then.
So stew,
like,
who knows how to put a headlock on
someone.
He's flexing his,
his uh,
his forearm.
Yeah.
Which is still not so bad.
A forearm and he's got this guy's face
is just,
he's just,
he's like,
he's stepped in a bear trap.
Plus he's absolutely shocked that this
old guy got him.
And so he's kind of gasping.
Stu says something like,
you watch,
if I flex this muscle just right,
and you can see this vein on his
forehead start to pop out.
It's extraordinarily funny,
20 ways Bret Hart plays out the good guy
archetype and Brett's like,
he's a solid guy,
but he's,
I would say he's not particularly
sophisticated and I'm not being cruel
about that.
I mean he had a great career and he's
tough as a boot and so good for him.
But he plays out this,
this good guy archetype and he gets
tangled up in it.
And now I don't remember your damn
question but I am trying to answer it.
Tell me the question again.
Oh yes,
yes.
Okay.
Exactly.
Well,
so one of the things I really liked
about this movie was it showed me why
people watched wrestling and I couldn't,
I couldn't because certainly they are
not appealing and I'm not being.
There are different strata of conception
of abstraction that any entertainment
process has to appeal to.
And you know,
most people don't go to movies and
that's actually because it really is
because movies operate at a level of
sophistication that are too high,
that is too high for many people just
like novels.
I mean hardly anyone reads,
you know,
and if,
if you about 15 percent of the
population might be 20 percent cannot
read well enough to follow written
instructions and so [inaudible] and
people who are,
maybe it's 15 percent of the population
or 10 percent have never finished a
book,
never.
And so,
and it is that high,
but you still,
you're still,
the archetypes still needs to manifest
itself at different levels and so it
manifests itself in wrestling,
but even there where it is physical
force,
it's not just physical force like it's a
drama between good and evil and you can
see this so clearly and in there Brett
Hart documentary because he's the good
guy and you know,
the bad guys are really over the top
bad.
It's a real drama.
It's like it's good versus evil in the
rain every time.
And hopefully good winds but good often
gets,
you know,
maybe the bad wrestler brings two of his
friends in and they bring in chairs and
they bashed the hell out of the good
guy.
And the whole audience is just outraged
by this.
And and the documentary does a lovely
job of showing that,
but so even at the level of physical
combat,
let's say you can't reduce what's good
to what strong,
it's just one element of it better to be
strong than to be weak and so you can
have a strong hero because it's better
to be strong than to be weak,
but it's better to be strong and kind
than to be strong and it's better to be
strong and kind and wise than to be
strong and kind.
And so.
And that's true not only for human
beings but it's even true,
let's say at the wolf for the chimpanzee
level because one of the things you see
with the chimp dominance hierarchies if,
and I think I mentioned this before,
is if the leader,
the dominant male is really good at
fostering social relations and being
reciprocal in acts like grooming and
also paying attention to the females and
their offspring.
His dynasty will be much more stable and
so strong might be good for one battle.
It might be good for two battles,
but for 50 battles it's not optimized.
Especially because no law,
no matter how strong you are,
someone can take you out.
So,
so what happens is the idea of what's
ideal becomes increasingly complex
across time,
multifaceted,
right,
and so strength,
wisdom,
intelligence,
vision,
all these things are amalgamated into a
single B and we'll talk a lot about that
because I want to show you how that
happened in Mesopotamia because that's
one of the first places where we have
documentation about how that ideally
merged.
They have a god called Marduk and Martin
had 50 names and as far as I can tell,
the reason for that was that Martech was
an amalgam of the tribal deities of at
least 50 tribes and and when the tribes
were brought together and civilized,
each of their gods who were ideals had
to be a male debated in something that
was a single,
a single dramatized representation of
value.
Or there was no way that all those
people could have lived together.
Right?
There are different value structures
would have fragmented them and they
would have stated in a state of war.
And so the question is,
what's the question you're asking?
If it's not strength than what is it?
Well straight,
there's an element,
but the Egyptians figured out that it
was vision is actually the capacity to
pay attention.
That was paramount and the Mesopotamians
have that figured out more or less too
because they're god Marduk had eyes all
the way around his head.
He could see everywhere.
So seeing was a critical element of what
should be on top.
And the other thing for the Mrs Heyman's
was the ability to speak.
So by the time of Mesopotamia,
people had already dramatized the idea
that the cardinal human attributes,
our vision and the ability to speak so
and that'd be the ability to speak the
truth,
to not just speak.
So other questions
mean that wasn't really aware of.
So is that why we sort of considered,
because we were talking earlier that
different levels of obstruction of
celebrity perspective,
more like reality TV.
Incredible being lower than a match than
a theater actor.
Then like a novelist.
Yes.
That's exactly why.
Because you see the less sophisticated
the genre,
the more the genre is like real life and
the more sophisticated it is,
the more it has abstracted out across
instances of real life,
the fundamental lessons.
And that's what makes something profound
and deep.
It's abstracted from multiple.
And that applies across multiple
dimensions because that's what you want.
So like,
and here's why.
Fundamentally,
so there are,
you have a problem,
but that's not the problem.
The problem is that there are problems.
So the problem is a Meta problem.
There are problems.
You need a solution to that.
That's not a solution to a problem,
that's a medical solution to the class
of problems.
Right?
Right.
And that's what people have been trying
to figure out ever since we were able to
actually figure things out.
It's not how do you solve a problem,
how it's,
how do you act so that you solve the
problem of problems and that's basically
at least the complexity of life and the
fact that you're mortal and vulnerable.
So,
so follow up question from your book.
You have this sort of strata from play
all the way up to religion and then
beyond that sort of looking back
practically with philosophy
irrationality.
Yes.
Israel is.
Well,
that's.
That's a good one.
A good.
I would say,
wait,
if you really want to think this
through,
the best way to do that is to read
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky at the same
time.
Now I'm sure there's other ways of doing
this,
but Nisha was actually quite heavily
influenced by Dostoevsky more than
people knew.
Although there are thought runs very
parallel and so Dostoevsky is like the
ultimate dramatist,
right?
He embodies his ideas and he has them
act out in a dramatic space.
It's literary whereas niche has taken
that up one level of abstraction to this
semantic.
He says,
well,
here's what's going on in an articulated
way,
but he doesn't embody it in the story
and you might say,
well that's.
That's higher,
but it's only hire in a way.
It's more abstract in that it's more
like words.
Whereas what Dostoevsky does is half
words and half images,
right?
Because when you read a novel,
what happens is that people say,
and the postmodernist say,
well,
where the hell's the meaning in that
novel?
It's like,
it's not in the word,
it's not in the phrase,
it's not in the sentence.
It's not in the paragraph,
you know,
where do you localize the meaning?
Great question.
Their answers sucks,
but the questions great.
So,
but what happens partly when you're
reading a book is that a novel is that
the words trigger representations in
your imagination and a lot of the
information from which a lot of what you
extract the information from is actually
your images,
stick representation of the words and
that image is to representation is
richer than the words because it's
informed by all of your knowledge about
people.
And so you,
you know,
this happens because you go to a movie
like the Harry Potter movies and you
say,
that's not how I imagined it,
right?
The probability that there'll be a one
to one correspondence between your
internal representation of the book and
the movie is zero,
and usually the movie is less rich than
the book.
I,
I love movies.
And they have their own place,
that's for sure,
but they're well mini series or the
series now are more approaching the
complexity and depth of literature
because they can extend across 20 hours,
you know,
and you know,
they don't have to compress a 12 hour
reading experience into two hours of
action.
So yeah.
And so what I was trying to do with that
hierarchy was to show how the knowledge
moved.
Like first of all,
it's kind of implicit in your biology
and then it's distributed into society
and then by imitating society you make
it part of your procedures and then you
watch your own procedures and start to
build a representation of them.
And then you can articulate that
representation.
And it's a,
it's a bootstrapping process too because
once you've made the representation that
can affect the way you behave.
And so they start to loop.
And so like.
So here's one thing,
one idea.
So imagine that,
imagine that there's a type of male who
tends to win dominance hierarchy contest
and to merge at the top.
While that's the case,
that is the case.
And that's why you're the way you are.
And so what's happened among human
beings,
this is so cool,
is that human females are choosy maters.
So about twice as many men,
men fail in their reproductive efforts
as females fail.
Okay?
But the man who succeed are more
successful.
So women are on average,
more successful and men are on average,
more failures and more successful.
And I'm talking strictly about
reproduction here,
although it generalizes to other areas,
but I'm talking about reproduction.
So how does it work exactly?
Well,
the women have a real trouble,
real problem with mate selection.
It's like who the hell are you going to
have as a mate?
And it's too complex to work out.
So women in their genius don't they let
the men compete and then they peel from
the top,
acting out the assumption that the man
who wins is the best man.
And it's a good assumption because if
you have a bunch of men competing,
especially if they're competing across
competitions and someone pops up at the
top,
you can think,
well,
they may not be worth much,
but they're better than anyone else at
whatever it is that they're doing,
and that makes men at the top of
dominance hierarchy is very attractive
to women.
And then the women accelerate that so
you can imagine they're more likely to
reproduce.
And so what happens is that the
proclivity to emerge at the top of the
set of dominance hierarchies becomes
inbuilt into the biology across time.
And the women exaggerate that by
differentially allowing them then to
reproduce.
And that's also why their mother nature,
they really are mother nature.
There's,
it's not just a metaphor.
And so then the representation and the
biology start to tangle together and
that's like,
well,
that's the difference between a meme in
an archetype,
right?
A meme is this idea that propagates
itself,
but an archetype is an idea that has
propagated itself across such as massive
span of time that it's actually shaped
the course of evolution.
And Man,
you can tell you already how this,
it isn't necessarily that you even have
to compete with other men in order to
see who wins as soon as you admire
someone and that'll happen
unconsciously.
You won't,
we won't be able to stop yourself.
You've already elevated them in the
dominance hierarchy contest.
The act of admiration is your
recognition that you've met someone
who's better at what ever it is that
happens to be driving your admiration
than you are.
And so,
and that's part,
that's partly the manifestation of just
the idea as the,
as the,
uh,
what would you say as the representation
of,
as the ideal.
And kids do that all the time.
They hear a worship other kids usually
like a four year old will latch onto
some six year old who will just follow
her show photo everywhere,
do exactly what they do.
And it's like,
well,
why?
Well,
because that person reps represents to
that child their next ideal there,
their conceptualization of the,
of the,
of the place forward.
So,
so.
Okay,
any other questions or should we maybe
call it a day?
Okay.
Oh,
when you said that the guy who was the
other thing was predatory bleeding,
which is insanity.
How do you define a Saturday in this?
Well,
let's,
let's call it what you don't want to
counter alone in an alley at midnight
and leave it at that.
But that is what I mean in this context.
That's exactly what I meet.
And then not only is the person they're
waiting for you,
but they're looking forward to whatever
might happen.
I just mean like in a psychological
contract using that word safe because
like as little connotation.
So I was thinking straddling.
No,
well the movie provides the,
the frame for the interpretation in this
particular situation and so he's the
thing that hauls naive young boys off to
their doom.
Okay.
So that's bounded.
So yes.
If you can elaborate a bit on.
You mentioned,
you talked about this mental process
where people do the thing that's hard,
but let's,
let's start,
but still facing the shadow.
That's actually a really productive way
of procrastinating.
Although it comes with its own problems
of rationalization,
so reinforces certain circuits.
I'll put it in a way that says that
those can go away,
so you need to bring up the the other
inhibitory circuits and they're just
wondering if you could elaborate.
Well,
I can sure is in the realm of
possibility around their understanding
of,
well,
I've derived out partly from my study of
addiction and also from my study of a
recovery from posttraumatic stress
disorder,
but let's talk about addiction.
So there's a series of actions that
occur before you take your cocaine.
Some of those are local.
They are the things that happened
immediately before and some of those are
distal.
They're farther back in the chain of
events and when you.
When you have a hit of cocaine,
it produces a dopaminergic burst and
that feels really good,
but it also makes the circuits that were
immediately active before that grow.
That's what reinforcement is,
and then the growth is proportionate,
not linearly,
but it's proportionate to how long
before that event occurred.
The closer it is,
the stronger they're going to get,
but even the ones that are somewhat
distal gets some reinforcement because
you might say,
well,
what did you do before?
You,
you found your latest fix and the answer
is well,
how long before?
Well,
the closer,
the more reward and so what happens then
is that,
so if you take that person out of the
normal environment,
you put them into a treatment center,
they're off.
There are physical addiction,
which is a weird thing in the case of
cocaine,
but I'm like not that long a week.
I'll do it two weeks for sure.
Even heroin and alcohol for sure,
if you can get them through the seizure
part without dying and so they're done.
They're done on physiologically
dependent anymore.
But you let that person go and the first
thing that happens is,
is an old friend who he's always out
doing drugs with shows up and bang,
he's craving like mad and that's because
that thing is in an area is not dead at
all and it's.
It's activated by the q and it's a.
it's a circuit.
It's not.
It's a personality.
It only wants one thing at once.
Cocaine,
it's going to suppress any non related
thoughts and it'll use lies.
That's no problem.
Especially if lies have been reinforced,
which they certainly have.
Where are you off to sun,
you know you'll have a live for that and
then 10 minutes later you have your drug
and so that little lie has just grown or
maybe you think you've tried to quit.
You think to hell with it and every
time,
10 minutes before you take your drug,
you think to hell with it and you do
that a thousand times.
Well,
believe me that to hell with it circuit,
that sucker is strong and so it's alive
and it's not like it just disappears.
It can't.
It's you.
It's grown in there.
Now you can build another circuit to
shut it down and you can help it
decompose across time by not giving it
what it wants,
but you're going to have to not give it
what it wants and all of the multiple
contexts that you've already associated
with the drug.
Some of you have probably smoked and
then tried to quit smoking and what
you'll see is you get a craving when.
Well,
when you have a cup of coffee or when
you're finished dinner,
when you're done.
Having a phone call or when you first
get up in the morning or whenever you've
regularly had the drug,
whatever you had the drug in
relationship to even complex things like
ending a conversation will produce a
cute craving and so then that can
extinguish overtime if you punish it by
either punishing it or not letting it
what it's wants,
but a lot you have to build another
circuit to just shut it down and then
that circuits kind of fragile and stress
can often disrupt it so
that can be read about quitting smoking
or things like,
oh sure.
Well part of it while I begins a whole
different thing because it seems to have
a direct physiological effect,
but you know,
the,
the addiction has a cognitive component.
It's full of thoughts and desires and
wants and you know,
you may have to build a,
you have may have to rebuild your whole
personality in order to,
to get that thing cornered.
Religious conversion for example,
is in a really effective treatment for
alcoholism.
That's partly why alcoholic alcoholics
anonymous works for the people for whom
it does work,
but religious conversion,
which is total personality conversion is
actually one of the few things that we
know of that's an effective treatment
for alcoholism.
We don't know how to induce it,
but although that's not exactly true
either because I'm in the early work
with Lsd was lsd was quite promising as
a treatment for for an alcohol addiction
and there's recent work with psilocybin
and showing that if you.
If people have a mystical experience
when you give them suicide and their
success rate and quitting smoking is
about 80 percent,
which is way higher than any
pharmacological intervention for smoking
has ever beat.
So.
Alright,
we should probably call it a day,
so we'll see you in a week.